Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Lino. Guten Morgen Tim.
Was du dann eigentlich auch noch auf der äh Toilettenparty.
Was bei der Toilettenparty passiert, bleibt bei der Toilettenparty.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik, die hundert äh sechsundsechzigste Sendung, oder? Ja.
Hundertsechsundsechzig.
Hundertsechsundsechzig. Und äh insofern,
so die erste hier wieder aus der Metaebene nach diesem kleinen Intermezzo in Hamburg. Von dem der geneigte Hörer wahrscheinlich schon mitbekommen hat, weil wir ja die Aufzeichnung schon veröffentlicht haben.
Genau, wir haben ja Aufzeichnungen, es gibt es gibt Aufzeichnungen von von dem Ereignis.
Ereignis. Genau, wer da noch nicht reingehört hat, ihr seht dann zwei vollkommen.
Ausgelaugte durchgepowerte äh heißere und nur noch mit fünfzig Prozent Stimmkraft sprechende Lokbuchnetzpolitikmoderatoren.
Das meinst du, ich dachte, mein Kongress ever.
Nee, ich meinte jetzt erstmal unser unser Ding da, was wir dann äh gemacht haben.
Ja und ein sehr gut gelaunten Ulf, der topfit ist und die Show schmeißt und das war ja auch ehrlich gesagt, der Plan, der.
Jemanden der fit ist, wir brauchen jemanden, der gut reden kann, wir brauchen immer.
Tag.
Jemanden, der juristisch den Hintergrund hat. Wir brauchen jemanden, der eine andere Perspektive bringt.
Genau. Bring in the Ulf. Ja, der der Plan ist gut aufgegangen, weil wie wie wir das schon geahnt haben, so am dritten Tag äh ich träume immer so ein bisschen davon, dass dieser Kongress eigentlich eigentlich brauche, fünf Tage,
ich merke auch das ist schon.
Wer soll das denn aushalten?
Ja, also es ist das ist wirklich die die ich glaube das das mehrheitlich die physische Belastungsgrenze äh einfach erreicht ist dann schon.
Absolut. Also ich habe ja,
Auch äh dann am einunddreißigsten, glaube ich, sehr klar festgestellt, wer also nach dem Kongress noch Energie hat für irgendwelche Festivitäten zum Silvester oder neuen Jahr,
falsch gemacht.
Ich bin noch ganz kurz auf so einer Silvesterparty aufgetaucht, nur um zehn Minuten später schon wieder zu bereuen. Dann habe ich mir so, oh, was machst du hier eigentlich.
Dazu darfst du keine Energie mehr haben. Du musst es genauso kalku
dass du am nächsten, also am einunddreißigsten irgendwann morgens in so ein ICE fällt und zu dem Zeitpunkt brauchst du noch einmal Energie, um Fahrkarten zu kaufen,
um dann nochmal mit der S-Bahn nach Hause zu fahren und da die Tür aufzuschließen. Wenn du Glück hast, schaffst du es dann noch zum Bett.
Hast du's geschafft?
Knapp.
So macht man das.
Ja andererseits, abgesehen von der,
von der physischen Erschöpfung gibt's natürlich auch so einen so eine psychische Kick irgendwie. Also ich meine dieser Kongress, der, der, der, der macht einen ja auch total irre.
Eben also Kick einerseits, aber du brauchst ja dann auch mal also ich habe ein paar Tage wirklich Bettruhe gebraucht, um das alles irgendwie mal zu verarbeiten.
Ja, ich glaube, für dich war's auch diesmal doch mal deutlich härter als für mich.
Das kann sein, aber also ich ich bin auch erst.
Ist so. Ich meine, du hast eine Eröffnung gemacht. Du hast einen gemacht und du hast dazwischen noch einen oder.
Jahresrückblick und ein Lokbuchnetz-Politik. Dann noch ein paar äh paar äh Pressebetreuung und Interviews.
Journalisten, ja. Ja ja und dann noch.
Und dann noch diese Chance, die dann diese Chance, die müsst ihr auch.
Da bin ich ja auch dabei. Ja und der also ich würde sagen, du hast das noch so einen Hauch äh wilder geritten, das äh Kongresspferd als als ich, aber unterm Strich waren wir dann beide im Eimer.
Trotzdem viele, viele, viele freiwillige Helfer, die da noch sehr viel mehr,
Energie reinstecken und das bei Aufgaben, die vielleicht nicht ganz so glamourös und dankbar sind und äh die haben da auf jeden Fall noch sehr viel mehr investiert als ich. Ich glaube, ich habe eher den Fehler gemacht
ähm meine eigenen Regeln nicht zu befolgen und irgendwie auch so ein,
allgemeinen Energiehaushalt zu achten. Also wir waren irgendwie am Ende von Tag zwei waren wir da mal was essen. War krass.
Echt lecker.
Ja, also wer es noch nicht gemerkt hat, wir reden natürlich vom zweiunddreißigsten Chaos Communication Kongress, außer nun ist zweiunddreißig C drei in Hamburg äh tausend Mal vorgestellt, angekündigt äh und dann auch vielfältig besucht, ausverkauftes Haus
Leider muss man sagen, also einerseits freut uns natürlich der Zuspruch. Auf der anderen Seite äh denken wir alle so ein wenig, hm,
mit Schaudern äh zurück auf die äh letzten ein, zwei Jahre in Berlin, als wir da noch im Berliner Kongresscenter waren und die Räumlichkeiten eigentlich für die Nachfrage schon viel zu klein waren, weil das den Kongress,
auf 'ne bestimmte Art unter Druck gesetzt hat die nicht schön war, weil man weiß, Leute bleiben weg, die eigentlich da wären und so weiter
neue Leute sind da, treffen dann aber wiederum nicht die Leute vor, die hier eben sonst da wären und, und, und, und dann kriegte das auf einmal alles so so eine Dyskontinuität und die ist
nicht gut für so eine Veranstaltung, die so extrem von ähm tradierten Erfahrungen äh lebt wie der Kongress.
Und von daher war es ja auch sehr schön zu sehen, dass jetzt mit den äh neuen Räumlichkeiten im CCH sich das Ganze einfach mal so richtig schön
gesund äh durchatmen konnte. Und das hat man ja auch gemerkt, die letzten
Vier Jahre waren einfach der Blas, das war einfach das, das Beste, was dieser Veranstaltung je passiert ist,
und ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass man in dass man jetzt gemerkt hat, dass man jetzt schon, also die Grenze war zwar jetzt erreicht worden, aber es hat sich noch nicht auf die Veranstaltung ausgewirkt, nicht nachhaltig zumindest.
Aber wieder, wenn, wir sind viele Leute das erste Mal da gewesen, haben diesen Kongresseffekt erlebt, ne. Ich weiß nicht, wird dir wahrscheinlich eh nicht gegangen sein, da kommen dann so Leute auf einen zu und sagen so, ja, du hast immer gesagt, das ist
kann es nicht beschreiben, jetzt weiß ich, was du gemeint hast, so. Und ähm tja,
denke, dass die Nachfrage tendenziell eher noch steigt, auch gerade nach diesem Kongress, der insgesamt einfach wieder eine sehr runde Sache war und dafür, dass er,
unter den äh erschwerten Bedingungen eines vorher noch zelebrierten Camps gelitten hat,
Die Aufzehrung der organisatorischen äh Kräfte betrifft oder auch einfach nur der Zeit, die man äh entsprechend nicht hatte, weil erstmal diese andere Veranstaltung organisiert und äh auch danach wieder abgewickelt werden musste.
Trotzdem noch so eine runde Geschichte bei rausgekommen ist, die eigentlich alle Leute sehr froh gemacht hat, dass zeigt eigentlich,
diese Veranstaltung im ja im Herzen dieser äh Szene getragen wird und dann auch immer wieder von vielen Leuten frisch ausgespielt wird und das sich äh diese Selbsterhaltungskräfte da einfach aufs Beste,
äh der Begeisterung vermengen.
Aber schon.
Jetzt schön färberisch unterwegs schon.
Nee, das also ist man hat schon.
Also man hat es glaube ich als Besucher der Veranstaltung nicht festgestellt,
Aber so insbesondere im Vorlauf der Veranstaltung schon gemerkt, dass da eben dieses Camp halt so ein,
Energieloch gerissen hat,
ähm was sich auf vielfältige Weise bei allen möglichen Leuten unterschiedlich äußert,
und ähm gleichzeitig aber natürlich auch alle freudig wieder dort in Hamburg fahren und die Veranstaltung halt großartig war. Also ich habe ehrlich gesagt, ich meine, wenn du so dann irgendwann im,
September so dich vom Camp erholt hast und dann so sagst so,
Scheiße, ist bald Oktober und dann ist Kongress so, in dem Moment, wenn du an den zurückdenkst und dann schaust, wie der Kongress dieses Jahr geworden ist,
Das äh war schon sehr beeindruckend. So, hättest du hätte ich in dem Zeitpunkt nicht mit gerechnet. Ich habe irgendwie so zwischenzeitlich gedacht, so na ja, vielleicht merkt's ja keiner, wenn wir den einfach nicht machen so, aber.
Ja aber das ist das, was ich meine und ich kenne das ja nun schon auch äh wir hatten das ja nun schon ein paar Mal mit dem mit dem Camp
und ähm darin da zeigt sich dann einfach, wenn eben auch bestimmte Leute äh einfach nicht mehr so richtig,
durchmarschieren können, wie sie es sonst gemacht haben, dann kommt von irgendwo ein Lichtlein her und neue Leute äh treten einfach aufs Parkett und und und reißen dann einfach äh den Rest an sich. Das, das, das findet halt einfach statt,
Also spätestens vor Ort, ja, also das.
Okay, nächstes Mal Karren, das alles nur dahin und sagen.
In meiner im Prinzip ist es ja auch schon so, wenn man sich anschaut, klar, da muss schon einiges im Vorfeld organisiert werden, aber wenn man mal,
Zur Kenntnis nimmt das eigentlich dieser Kongress jetzt vielleicht mal mit der Ausnahme der,
Dekoration und Partylocation, aber das war so der der Kernevent eigentlich erst so am fünfundzwanzigsten alle kommen. Auch alle Helfer dann erst kommen und dass sich das dann einfach innerhalb weniger Stunden
so in die in in die Breite der Teilnehmerschaft die Arbeit rein verteilt und die dann einfach so ganz organisch natürlich aufgenommen wird,
Dieses Event.
So, dann wollen wir mal.
Vielleicht auch mal inhaltlich ein wenig beleuchten, was da gelaufen ist.
Vom vom na ja Eigenlob ist es ja nicht, was wir jetzt gemacht haben.
Nee, das ist,
der Szene, das ist das ist gar nicht unser äh unser Beitrag und äh ich habe da auch so eine gewisse auch erlernt mit der Zeit. Das selbst wenn man viel macht,
nicht nichts davon würde am Ende irgendwie funktionieren, wenn es nicht halt auf dieses dieses Systemkongress, was einfach in in allen verankert ist, aufschlagen würde.
Ja und würde auch, würde also wäre auch ist in der Gesamtmenge, das ist eigentlich das das Interessanteste, in der Gesamtmenge ist der einzelne Beitrag eben immer nur so ein so ein Fliegenschiss, egal, was du machst,
Und aber dieser riesige, ich sage jetzt mal, ähm Ameisenhaufen, der da entsteht, ist halt äh ist halt Wahnsinn und.
Wir hatten ja gerade bei der, auch bei der Vorbereitung des Closing Events, so dieses dieses Problem,
Alle Besucher erleben eine ganz andere Veranstaltung, weil es eben diese Veranstaltung ist so groß und so vielfältig, dass es längst keinen,
roten Faden mehr gibt, der sich durch alle, durch alles für alle zieht, ja? Selbst sowas wie die Haupttalks in der,
Im großen Saal die Main Events können nur von einem Viertel der Besucher besucht werden. Ja, also.
Ja also.
Keinen roten Faden drin und entsprechend ist es auch ähm schwierig darüber zu,
sprechen.
Ohne darauf hinzuweisen, dass es sich um eine individuelle subjektive Auswahl und Erfahrung handelt. Aber trotzdem sollten wir mal versuchen, so ein bisschen über den ähm,
Wir haben jetzt einfach mal die, die, die Liste der Aufzeichnungen aufgemacht und scrollen da jetzt mal so ein bisschen durch und wollen ein paar empfehlen und erwähnen, ähm,
Disclaimer dazu ähm in dem in dem Bereich Politik werden wir natürlich unseren Schwerpunkt legen aufgrund des der des Vorkommens dieses Wortes in unserem Sendungstitel,
und ähm.
Wobei ich gestehen muss.
An einer oder anderen Stelle mal.
Ich habe viel, ich habe schon wirklich viel, viel mehr Talks nachgehört, als, glaube ich, in den ganzen Jahren zusammengenommen zuvor,
Ich bin gerade hier in unserem Kernkompetenzbereich
da lauern noch viele äh äh Lücken. Also ich habe viel äh netzpolitische Sendung nicht mitgenommen.
Auch ganz bewusst, weil ich das einfach das ganze Jahr hier über äh besprochen habe und ähm in gewisser Hinsicht erstmal das Bedürfnis gespürt habe, mich mal in den anderen Disziplinen äh,
neu aufzutanken.
Ja und also mein Disclaimer ist noch, dass ich jetzt natürlich auch gleichzeitig dieses Programm in im Politikbereich größtenteils an der Auswahl beteiligt war.
Das ist der Vorteil, aber wir wir können das ja hier bunt mischen und und und äh bieten euch sozusagen ein sowohl netzpolitische äh netzpolitisch und generell politisch angehauchte Auswahl plus äh X.
So machen wir das. Und.
Mache dann das X.
Minus die Teile, die wir selber vielleicht auch noch nicht gesehen haben.
Ja, ja, da ist auf jeden Fall noch einiges zu holen. Das wird nicht der einzige Kongressüberblick sein, aber wir wollen jetzt natürlich, jetzt, wo die Erinnerung so frisch ist, dass hier auch mal ein bisschen breiter aus äh breiten, weil ich denke mal, das erwartet Sie auch von uns.
Und wir Linken natürlich auf die uns allen bekannte und geehrte Adresse Media
Punkt CC Punkt DE. Äh denn dort gibt es die Talks in allen möglichen Sprachen und äh
Übersetzungen ähm in reinen quäl offenen, schönen Formaten,
Zum direkten Download oder auch zum Download.
Und sie stehen unter einer sehr freien CC Lizenz, nämlich ich glaube einfach nur CC bei. Und das hält viele,
ähm oder einige wenige Leute natürlich nicht davon ab, sie auf YouTube zu veröffentlichen und mit Werbung zu versehen, auf das man damit,
generieren könne, ähm das ist natürlich für die ganze Arbeit, die das äh,
Videooperation Center des CCC sich mit dem aufzeichnenden Film und Stream der Veranstaltung macht,
eine äh eine sehr unschöne Maßnahme, aber ähm,
Offenbar sieht es im Moment noch danach aus, dass wir das zumindest weiterhin dulden werden im Sinne der freien Lizenzen, die wir natürlich alle stützen. Aber äh wer ähm,
auf Media CC die Aufzeichnung schaut, sorgt dafür, dass äh,
Ein Arschloch irgendwo auf der Welt weniger Geld verdient und das ist doch schon mal nicht schlecht.
Ich gucke gerade mal. Ich weiß jetzt gerade gar nicht, was jetzt.
Wo du guckst, ne?
Ich äh.
Was schaust du denn? Wir fangen doch jetzt einfach mal an hier mit.
Ja ja, warte mal. Ich wollte nur mal kurz äh kurz schauen.
Also wir schauen uns die Liste an und mir fällt als erstes ins Auge, nämlich geordnet nach dem Veröffentlichungsdatum ist das.
Ja, aber dann gehen wir, gehen wir, gehen wir von dem älteste, äh von dem von dem Ersten los, also von unten sozusagen, aber kann ja hier nur äh absteigen.
Ja, machen wir von mir aus von unten nach oben, ja. Ähm den habe ich nicht gesehen.
Ja, da war das der war ähm sehr früh am ersten.
Ja, die habe ich gesehen, dass ähm,
Tatsächlich ganz interessant, geht's jetzt nicht so um Politik, aber äh Holger Kriege ist recht erfolgreich mit äh verschiedenen EU-Projekten gewesen, also hat sich da sozusagen was zuteilen lassen, wer von euch mal äh erwägt Förderung zu erhalten,
Ähm auf EU-Ebene, weil da gibt's diverse Programme, auch für so äh Hacker orientierte äh Themen
der Talk ist eben ganz konkret über die Anforderungen und was man da sozusagen tun sollte bei der Beantragung,
um einfach ja,
Open Projekte äh gefördert zu bekommen und das auf jeden Fall mal sehr interessant, weil hier geht's halt nicht so um die Technik, sondern hier geht's sozusagen mehr ums Hacken der EU und,
Holger ist da ein Kundiger, Experte.
Radio Plus Plus von Sec und Schneider, die äh das Radio Batch entwickelt haben, dass wir beim äh Camp verschenkert haben.
Habe ich gesehen.
Hast du auch gesehen?
Also das, ich meine, da die muss man natürlich einfach abfeiern. Also diese Leistung, überhaupt diese diese Engineering Leistung, dieses Ding zu bauen, zu produzieren zu lassen. Ähm
Die ist ja schon einfach zu würdigen und dann natürlich auch noch dieser ähm,
Diese Weiterentwicklung des Tools und was ihr da jetzt noch alles weitergebaut haben in den wenigen Monaten, das ist halt sehr beeindruckend und ähm denke ich ein besonderes Beispiel, auch so, wenn man,
sich irgendwie die Frage stellt, was ist eigentlich diese Chaos, Computergroup, dass man da mal äh schaut, so was was für,
Leute das sind, die da wirklich den Club atmen.
Äh auch sehr schön, weil sie äh auch äh eine Menge dokumentieren, was alles nicht so gut gelaufen ist, weil das ja noch eine sehr kurzfristige Produktion war.
Fixbare Probleme, nicht fixbare Probleme mit Workarounds, wie man damit umgeht, was so an Software und an Ideen äh aufgekommen ist. Also wer äh auf dem Camper und so ein Radio Bach hat und vielleicht noch nicht genau weiß, was damit äh geschehen soll
reinschauen. Die müssen wir jetzt auch alle verlinken, ne? Oh ja. Aber wir verlinken jetzt nicht alle,
So, nächstes Jahr.
Hm, oh, Opening Event, ja, Opening Event gab's auch, da kann ich vor allem die äh die Videoanimation am Anfang sehr empfehlen,
von äh Freunden von mir, dem CCC geschenkt, äh Frederick Brückner,
Erich Lesowski und Roland Brückner haben da so die Hauptarbeit gemacht. Das glaube ich, kann sich auf jeden Fall sehen lassen und danach gibt's noch so ein paar freundliche Worte.
Ja, kommen wir vielleicht nochmal kurz was zum Design sagen, das fand ich äh doch unterm Strich sehr, sehr gelungen. Äh das war ein sehr kurzfristige Aktion, aber äh was ich erstaunlich fand, ist, obwohl das so eigentlich,
Wann wann wurde das veröffentlicht? Zwei Wochen vor vor Beginn der Veranstaltung?
Was würde zwei Wochen.
Das Design.
Also das Design, ja, zwei.
Das äh also diese diese Designlinie selber, die wurde erst sehr kurz vor der Veranstaltung überhaupt sich.
Ja, könnte ich noch mal schauen, aber so ungefähr also.
War nicht mehr als drei.
Zwei Wochen höchstens, ja. Es war so ein bisschen beabsichtigt.
Und trotzdem, trotzdem, na ja, ein Gutmarkt beabsichtigt gewesen sein
fände es auch mal ganz schön, wenn's vielleicht demnächst mal gelingt, das ein bisschen früher zu machen, weil
man eben sieht, wie sehr es doch aufgenommen wird. Also wie viele modifizierte Varianten von anderen Logos es gab und wie damit rumgespielt wurde und so. Das äh war schon sehr schön. Ich weiß nicht, wo äh äh bei wie vielen von den einzelnen dann teilweise äh die Truppe selber noch äh mit angepackt hat.
Aber.
Also die, die wir haben, das Design war ja ähm hauptsächlich Roland Brückner, mein guter Freund,
ähm der hat,
Wir haben sehr viel halt für was weiß ich, für Essen, für Workshops, für alles mögliche, für die SIM-Karten äh für die,
Eintrittskarten zur Turnhalle für die Beschilderung schon immer Sachen ähm angefertigt,
und unter der Hand, also quasi im Orgabereich dieses Design schon stark zirkuliert. Aber es gab halt einen Grund, warum ich das so ein bisschen auch erst spät ähm.
Gehe,
released habe das Design und das war das ja in dem Opening Event, diese Flasche geöffnet wird. Und es gab ja quasi dieser dieser Effekt, dass die Flasche eigentlich anfangs nur geschlossen bekannt war und allen,
Gezeigt wurde, ähm,
Und dann eben bei dem Opening Event feierlich eröffnet wurde. Das fand ich irgendwie äh fand ich ganz witzig, aber ich glaube, das war von der für die Leute, die äh das Design auch adaptieren wollen und,
und in ihren einzelnen Projekten damit arbeiten und das weiterentwickeln wollen, ein bisschen suboptimal, vor allem, dass es auch durch diesen Zeichenstil halt eigentlich eine klare, die gab auf jemanden, der halt,
in bestimmten Stil illustrieren kann, eben in dem Roland da entwickelt hat. Ähm hat Vor- und Nachteile,
Ich fand's diesmal mir das Design sehr gut gefallen. Es gibt natürlich auch immer wieder Leute, denen es dann nicht gefällt. Ähm so läuft das halt.
Ja äh nächster Talk hier in der Liste habe ich auch gesehen, Dieselgate.
Ja, oh, das war, das war auch spannend, da hatten wir, wir hatten die Einreichung von Daniel Lange und dann irgendwie so in der
In der vergammelte dann nochmal
Eine Anfrage oder ein Hinweis ausm Dezember schon längst von Felix äh Domke, der so schrieb, ja,
Ich habe hier mir so ein bisschen Units von Volkswagen angeschaut. Wenn ihr noch ein bisschen Platz habt, ähm,
Wäre cool, wenn ich einen Lightning Talk halten könnte. So, so ungefähr, ja. Und diese Anfrage war jetzt halt schon längst Dezember war, ist irgendwie auch noch mal ein paar Tage liegen geblieben
bis sich dann irgendwie durch Zufall darüber stolperte
bei so einem Content-Meeting und sagte, guck mal hier und dann haben wir haben wir dann mit äh mit Felix und Daniel gesprochen und das war dann noch ein,
Ein wildes Hin und Her, die von einem, sage ich mal, moderat gut platzierten Talk ähm in einem der,
mittelgroßen Seele, ähm
auf in Sat1 zu legen und äh entsprechend auch abzufeiern. Haben wir aber hinbekommen. Und ähm der wurde enorm gut aufgenommen, ne?
Ja, das war dann auch in der Kombination sehr schön, weil Daniel hat halt äh im Prinzip die ganze politische äh Dimension, dieses äh Skandals aufgemacht und nochmal sehr schön erklärt, wie eigentlich so die ganzen Mechanismen
äh Automobilbereich funktionieren und ähm
Ich habe auch hintenrum von verschiedenen Stellen gutes sozusagen äh darüber gehört, was er gesagt hat aus aus Kreisen, die das auch kennen
äh und und Felix hat dann halt einfach diesen, diesen super Kongress Nerd äh Aspekt noch nachgeliefert mit so, ja, ich hatte so ein Auto, ich war da betroffen, ich habe das da ich habe dann da mal reingeschaut.
Ja, aber der hatte, der hat ja noch geschrieben. Ich habe mal reingeschaut, was da drin ist, wollte mein Auto aber nicht kaputt machen, deswegen habe ich mir noch mal einen baugleiches Teil von Ebay geholt.
Genau. Als sich das angeschaut und und das auseinandergenommen und einfach schöne äh äh Belege auch äh dafür, wie sich das dann eben auch Exploten lies und wie's wahrscheinlich dann auch gelaufen ist. Also geiler Talk.
Der hat der hat ja auch wirklich, sage ich mal, sehr klare politische Implikation, weil was der Felix da nachgewiesen hat, ist, dass die Engineering Control Unit, die Bosch, VW zur Verfügung stellt, nicht manipuliert ist,
Die ist quasi mal.
Sondern es ist nur ein Fleck gesetzt worden mit wir benutzen jetzt mal das Feature, was eh schon da.
Andere, die kriegt andere Inputdaten von dem VW kontrollierten Teil. Der gibt quasi andere Steuerungsparameter an die, sodass sie eben im Normalbetrieb in einem Ausnahmemodus läuft.
Und ähm das, ich meine, das kann irgendwann nochmal äh interessante rechtliche Implikationen haben für Bosch. Also die sind auf jeden Fall schon mal vom Haken so. Ähm das Ding scheint ähm,
VW ähm selber auslöffeln zu müssen. Da ist jetzt auch gerade wieder irgend so eine Klage in den USA anhängig.
Neunziger Milliarden kostet.
Ja, neunzehn Milliarden und dann geht der DAX unter zehntausend Punkte wundert man sich ja, ich meine, nehmen wir an, anschaust, was für einen Anteil VW am DAX hat, dann wunderst du dich nicht, aber okay, ja.
Das auf jeden Fall bahnbrechend und also auch so wirklich wo man dann auch ja so diese Mischung aus,
Hardcore-Hacker und dann noch irgendwie Insider, der mal ein bisschen teilt, das ist, glaube ich, verkörpert auch äh CCC mehr als ähm alles andere.
Annabiselli,
NSA Untersuchungsausschuss zwischen Aufklärungswillen und Mauern aus Schweigen war auch äh Tag eins, Saal eins natürlich und äh,
ein riesen Vortrag, also,
fand ich super. Und Anna ist echt jetzt nicht unbedingt der so ein Mensch, der sich jetzt auf eine Bühne drängt, ne. Aber die die haben insbesondere häufig den Vorteil, dass sie dann sehr, sehr gute Inhalte wiedergeben. Also hat mich sehr
hat mich auch sehr gefreut Pflichtprogramm.
Ja. Also ich habe ihn nicht gesehen, aber äh darum ging's jetzt. Das war sozusagen mal eine Zusammenfassung. Was ist in diesem Jahr im NSA OA gelaufen?
Genau, was ist da gelaufen? Und sie ist dann auch eingestiegen mit okay, was ist der Anspruch dieses Untersuchungsausschuss und was sind da jetzt auch natürlich die Kräfteverhältnisse, ne? Was sind da
Es geht ja dann los mit den mit den Verteilungen der Sitze über die Parteien. Das geht weiter mit irgendwelchen Interessen,
Der Geheimdiensteverflechtung zwischen Bundeskanzleramt und
ähm BND und der Aufsicht und welche Anwälte spielen da welche Rolle? Und äh wie positioniert sich
die Koalition in dem Bereich wie positioniert sie sich da und dann kommen natürlich auch für Klassiker wie die Weltraumtheorie und so. Das ist einfach mal äh eine schöne.
Da gab's ja noch ein zweites äh Special dazu.
Noch ein Special, das war aber dann auch äh im Track Entertainment, beziehungsweise Abendprogramm. Das war die Lesung aus den Protokollen. Ne, Anna ist ja bei Netzpolitik org, ähm schreibt ähm
dass jetzt die Hauptverantwortliche für das Anfertigen der Live Blog Protokolle aus dem äh Untersuchungsausschuss,
und ähm aus diesen Protokollen gab's dann eben auch im Abendprogramm zur Allgemeinen zum Unterhalten äh zur Unterhaltung der Leute eine ähm
eine Lesung, eine szenische Lesung hieß das, glaube ich.
Dann hatten wir,
Die Keynote natürlich, diesmal was, äh womit niemand gerechnet hat. Ähm das war ja auch dann natürlich so geplant. Ähm wir haben uns insbesondere unter Betrachtung des Mottos.
Communitys und unter Betrachtung der,
allgemeinen Großwetterlage nicht nur im Internet in Bezug auf Communitys, sondern auch in der äh wie kann man das nennen?
Tagespolitik, in der äh Migrationspolitik und so weiter ähm
eine Keynote-Speakerin eingeladen, die ähm eine
zweimalig äh Geflüchtete ist. Sie ist einmal von Somalia nach Kenia geflohen und einmal von Kenia nach Deutschland, ähm war in verschiedenen Auffanglagern ähm wie man sie, glaube ich, nennt, in ähm,
See und in Eisenhüttenstadt, bis sie dann irgendwann nach äh Berlin gegangen ist,
und sie äh hat eine will ich sagen, eine Außenperspektive auf,
ja, Europa und auf natürlich auch die Hacker geliefert. Ist ja teilweise auch, würde ich sagen, an einen ähm an schmerzhafte Punkte gegangen und ähm das äh,
War so gewollt und wurde auch von den meisten eben auch mit entsprechender ähm mit entsprechender Wertschätzung,
wahrgenommen. Kann man auf jeden Fall mal kann man sich mal anschauen.
Auf jeden Fall ungewöhnlich und überraschend.
In allen, in allen äh in allen Aspekten ungewöhnlich auch, weil sie einen Vortragsstil hat, der eine ganz andere,
Prägung hat, als man das jetzt vielleicht von einer klassischen Keynote erwarten würde.
Das das kann man wohl sagen.
Ich weiß schon, wie ich ausdrücke,
Aber ich denke, dass das Zeichen haben wir da auch als äh als Club gesetzt. Und darum ging's uns ja auch dabei.
Dann haben wir äh,
Würde ich sagen, auf unserer Liste jetzt nächstes Boilding, Digital Policy making mit äh Kirsten Fiedler, Kirsten Fiedler, jetzt lass mich überlegen, hatten wir die schon mal in der Sendung oder nicht? Ich meine, wir hatten sie vor einiger Zeit, ja, ne?
Wir hatten der einmal dabei.
So und,
Walter von Holz ein IT-Rechtler, der ja auch schon öfter mal bei äh Kongressen zu Besuch war. Ähm,
hat in diesem Jahr noch eine andere, noch ein anderes Panel geleitet, war beim einunddreißig C drei mit so einem mit so einer Kampfrede dabei in Focke,
in ja aber der halt so diese diese Brüssel Sache da im Auge hat und damit der Kirsten Fiedler von Etri,
mal so auf darauf geblickt hat, was so in Brüssel,
schief läuft und was die Herausforderungen der nächsten Zeit sind und diese ganze EU Geschichte ist ja grundsätzlich immer wichtig und interessant.
Jugend hakt.
Ja, Jugend hakt, Jugend hackt, ähm haben wir hier, glaube ich, auch schon das ein oder andere Mal
erwähnt, war halt jetzt auch mal auf dem Kongress präsent, war auch glaube ich das erste Mal, zumindest in der Form, als das äh das Projekt auch selber,
vor Ort war. Also neu war, dass es sozusagen einen richtigen,
ähm also einen sogenannten gab, also ein ein Ort, wo die Jugendlichen, die an diesem Projekt teilgenommen haben, andauern konnten,
Der Club hatte ja die Teilnehmer von Jugend-Akt auch eingeladen auf den Kongress zu kommen und soweit ich weiß, haben so zehn bis zwanzig Prozent oder so in der Größenordnung äh das Angebot auch angenommen.
Ähm ja, eher etwas über zwanzig Prozent.
Noch mehr, okay?
Du hast ja dann immer noch so Leute, die dann irgendwie noch mal einen Tag vorher. Ich war doch da eingeladen.
Na ja, ich hatte so so die Zahl von äh ein, zwei Wochen vorher so im im Kopf
Was ich für eine sehr, sehr gute Quote handele, äh halte, weil das ja immerhin noch Weihnachten ist und ne, nicht jeder traut sich und dann wurde eben äh auch die Projektpräsentation dort nochmal im Saal gemacht. Wir hatten die auch im Sendenzentrum,
dann noch mal mit etwas äh spezifischeren Diskussionsrunden zu den einzelnen Projekten zu Gast.
Das äh finde ich nach wie vor ein gutes Projekt, das passt auch gut zum Kongress, wie auch,
Ich finde, der Junghackertag am zweiten Tag äh ziemlicher Erfolg war, extrem viele Kids da waren,
ähm da war ein Gewusel in diesem Workshops, da wurde einfach äh alles verlötet, was bei 3D auf den Bäumen war und ja, das ist äh auf jeden Fall in den letzten Jahren zu einem guten Angebot geworden,
viel wird, sagen wir mal gemacht für die Kleinen,
wo vielleicht noch ein bisschen Luft nach oben ist, ist ein bisschen mehr darüber nachzudenken, wie man so ein bisschen die die Altersgruppe so ab vierzehn,
noch mal etwas expliziter mit einbezieht.
Also Tim, das ist doch Jugend-Hack. Das ist ja Jugend-Hacknis bis siebzehn, glaube ich. Und.
Ich rede jetzt vom Junghackertag und sozusagen, ja, also Jugend hackt nochmal eine andere äh Spreizung, aber grundsätzlich,
Ich sage nur, man kann sich da nochmal Gedanken machen. Ihr habt ja jetzt noch keine, keine, keine Rezepte, aber ähm das ist ja auch so ein bisschen diese,
Kinderabteilung, ja? Das ist so in den letzten zehn Jahren auch mit der äh,
zunehmenden mit dem Kinderreichtum der Clubmitglieder gewachsen
Ja, also wir hatten so vor fünfzehn Jahren das erste Mal so Diskussionen mit wollen wir uns mal um Kinderbetreuung irgendwie kümmern, damit Leute, die jetzt Kinder haben und seit Jahren aufm Kongress dabei sind, äh auch noch,
eine Möglichkeit haben. Da gab's halt einfach mal gar nichts. Und das ist schon äh sehr viel weitergekommen,
Es gibt eine Riesenzone für für Kids, wo sie sagen, für junge Kinder, also kleine Kinder, dass sozusagen die auch da sein können und die Eltern,
Den Kongress auch genießen können. So, wer ein Angebot an die
Eltern gewesen. Dann ist daraus sozusagen eine zunehmende Maße auch ein Angebot an diese Kinder geworden nach dem Motto, wir wollen euch hier nicht hier nur den ganzen Tag im Bällebad tauchen lassen, sondern wir wollen euch sozusagen auch Dinge zeigen und euch irgendwie heranführen und und und kompatible Angebote schaffen.
Ja, aber inzwischen ist es doch wirklich so, dass die, dass dann die Kinder da ihre Eltern hinziehen. Also das hat doch jetzt.
Das ist jetzt halt der nächste Trend, ja.
Also wir hatten ähm ich habe ja auch so ein bisschen die Einreichung oder die Anmeldung zu den Chaos-Patinnen gesehen. Da war dann auch so so Mails bei irgendwie so, wo dann äh Leute schreiben, ja ähm,
Meine Tochter konnte dieses Jahr nicht bei Jugend Hack teilnehmen, weil wir eine Familienfeierlichkeit hatten und deswegen schenke ich ihr zu Weihnachten ein Kongressticket,
aber die ist noch nicht ganz so alt, deswegen muss ich ja dann irgendwie mit. So also,
Und dann habe ich mir gedacht, dann gucke ich halt mal bei den Chaosparten rein. Meine Tochter macht da schon die braucht das nicht, aber ich das ist so.
Elternbetreuung sozusagen, damit die Kinder ungestört den Kongress genießen können. Ja, das ist äh ein schön.
Also das würde ich schon sagen, so dass dass es ist von da aus diesem, ja, wir müssen auch mal irgendwas machen, damit die Kinder ruhig sind. Da hat sich schon echt was was ganz anderes draus entwickelt. Und dann gibt's ja noch den den, also das Jugend,
Und den Junghackertag, den darf man ja auch wiederum nicht trennen. Äh nicht, nicht in einen Topf werfen mit dem Kids Base, den es ja auch noch gab,
von dem ich auch nur äh begeisterte äh begeistertes Feedback gehört habe, selber.
Eine Einschränkung.
Mit einer Einschränkung.
Es gab kein Lego dieses Jahr.
Was? Was sind die Lego gefahren? Warum haben die uns kein Lego gestellt.
Äh nee, es hat mit Gestell nichts zu tun. Normalerweise gibt es da eine Kraft, die über einen größeren Lego-Bestand verfügt, die aber aus,
bisher noch nicht bekannten Gründen schlicht nicht auftauchte, so. Ähm,
Ich will jetzt noch nicht gleich was lostreten, aber ich denke, es.
Nächstes Jahr gibt's wieder Logo.
Ist also erstens, es wird Lego geben. Die Frage ist wie und ähm ich würde es,
für eine gute Sache halten, wenn sich eine äh Gruppe fände, die sozusagen mal frühzeitig anfängt, Lego Spenden einzusammeln für den Kongress.
Sodass man einen eigenen Bestand aufbaut dafür, dass dann irgendwie in unserem Powerful Lager äh liegt,
Die Schlagkraft des äh des CCC Eventlagers äh in dieser strategisch wichtigen Bereich der Legoisierung der der Kids äh noch äh weiter verstärkt.
Gut, haben wir das auch.
Meister. Das ist jetzt so ein interner Aufruf.
Sehr intern, ja.
Na ja, ihr wisst schon. Irgendjemand muss sich dadrüber äh da drum kümmern. Wir brauchen einfach Lego spenden. Wir müssen das irgendwie einsammeln, waschen und in Kisten packen und auf Paletten und dann schieben wir das einfach strategisch auf den Kongress und dann ist das Thema auch durch.
Alles klar.
Strategische Ressourcen Lego, genau so wichtig wie wie wie Netzwerk Rauter und Molltonnen und.
Okay, ja ich.
Kabelbenauern heißt Kleo und so.
Douli Noted,
Wir hatten ähm noch ein politisches Panel. Da war dann auch wieder der Jurist Walter von Holst, äh Nade Cardoso von der,
Electronic frontiert Foundation, äh Richie, von dem ich immer den Nachnamen nicht aussprechen kann, tinnen oder teinen von ähm,
Privacy International und äh.
MLP, wo ich jetzt kurz nochmal nachschauen muss, wer das überhaupt war, wo ich das eigentlich wissen müsste. Ich gucke mal kurz in die Aufzeichnung.
Vor welchem Talk redest du jetzt gerade?
Cybers. Und zwar geht es da um diesen um das Spannungsfeld, das man ja jetzt irgendwie sehr gerne mal,
was machen würde um Waffenkontrollen,
Oder um Exportkontrollen für Cyberwaffen in irgendeiner Form hinzukriegen und zu erzwingen.
Und äh Cyberwaffen können natürlich jetzt alles Mögliche sein, ne. Äh,
Aber äh viele denken dabei natürlich dann auch an Staatstrojaner, also was ist zum Beispiel mit europäischen Unternehmen, die Staatstrojaner,
herstellen und in eben so Demokraturen und Diktaturen exportieren,
dann überlegt man sich natürlich, ob man da nicht was gegen tun kann. Äh Großbritannien hatte das ja auch schon äh damals groß angekündigt, gegenüber. Ähm Gamma,
Das Problem ist natürlich, dass es da in der Regel um Software geht und die kannst du halt in deinem Kopf äh oder auf einem USB-Stick mit einem Flugzeug überall hinfliegen,
und die kannst du auch über das Internet verschicken. Und
da sind natürlich Exportkontrollen wirklich sehr schwierig, sinnvoll umzusetzen, zumal
es jetzt einem einem Unternehmen, das Exportkontrollen umgehen will, äh ja nicht schwer fällt in Saudi-Arabien eine Briefkastenfirma zu gründen, äh die dann dort ein äh Produkt anbietet. Das heißt, das ist ein sehr schwieriges
Themenfeld, weil.
Ist dann eben auch die Arbeit von Sicherheitsforschern und äh die Veröffentlichung von Sicherheitstools ähm sehr stark erschweren kann, wie in Deutschland eben auch
der Hacker Paragraph, der eine große Unsicherheit
äh über den gesamten Bereich der IT-Sicherheitsforschung gebracht hat. Ähm entsprechend kontrovers wird das Thema diskutiert. Man hat einerseits eben,
sehr äh technische Security-Leute, die sagen, geht ja gar nicht, äh ist Quatsch, macht uns nur Ärger. Kann zu nix Positivem führen und ähm,
bringt nur Schaden mit sich. Und äh es gibt auf der anderen Seite
dann eben natürlich auch Bürgerrechtler, die sagen, ja okay, aber wir können auch bestimmte Praxen äh oder bestimmte Marktpraktiken, die hier stattfinden, in der Form nun wirklich nicht dulden. Und äh da gab es eben äh dieses Panel, was dieses äh Spannungsfeld da sehr schön,
darstellt.
Gut.
Was der nächste den du gesehen hast, ich könnte anführen.
Ich überlege jetzt gerade. Ja, führ doch mal an.
Ja, also äh.
Letzter Club ist ja, sollen wir noch kurz Let's and Grip nochmal erklären? Let's and Grip ist ist der Grund, warum Tim jetzt keine Ausrede mehr hat, Podcasts nicht über HTPS aus, der Blick, der Blick.
Du hast mit Apple noch nicht gerechnet.
Großartiges Projekt von äh der IFF angestoßen. Ähm zu sagen, okay es gibt jetzt einfach äh von,
allgemeinen Browsern äh allgemein akzeptierte HTTPS-Zertifikate beziehungsweise
nicht nur HTTP, sondern eben auch grundsätzlich TLS-Zertifikate äh kostenlos mit einer Tool-Chaine, ein ähm Projekt, das wir, dass ich mit sehr großer Freude und viel Wohlwollen betrachte,
dass gleichzeitig ähm,
Aber auch von äh von der Security-Seite ähm ein bisschen Kritik dafür bekommt, wie das,
Automatisierte Protokoll zum Erstellen eines Zertifikates abläuft. Wie es da implementiert ist. Also,
die Idealvorstellung ist wirklich, dass du einfach äh an deinem Rechner eingibst, ähm,
äh und dann
Äh let's cript schreibst. Minus Auto schreibst und der lässt automatisch funktioniert. Und das ist äh eher ähm noch nicht so wirklich der Fall. Und die Berechtigung, die diese Software dann braucht, um.
Auch wirklich automatisiert zu zu funktionieren steht von einigen Leuten in der Kritik ist da ein prominenter Erdgeist ist ein prominenter die da diese technische Implementierung harsch kritisieren. Ich,
Habe das eh eher manuell gemacht und äh freue mich über diese Zertifikate,
der Vortragende Roland Schuhmaker hat aber glaube ich,
Äh die Kritik bekommen ein bisschen Dröge über dieses bahnbrechende Projekt gesprochen zu haben.
Ach, es waren, ich würde sagen, einfach mal ein sehr sachlicher Vortrag
Also ich habe das nicht unangenehm. Also zumindest nicht als langweilig empfunden. Das äh hat ist einfach da äh mal konkret durchmarschiert. Das ist ja auch nur eine halbe Stunde und da ist auch noch ein bisschen QA mit drin. Also es war jetzt auch nicht äh außerordentlich ausführlich, aber äh hatte einfach mal die wesentlichen Sachen zusammengefasst und und und wie so ein bisschen der Stand der Dinge ist
von daher fand ich das irgendwie alles in Ordnung. Was die Kritik an Netz in Krypt betrifft, die halte ich für für.
Am Thema vorbei,
Ja, weil was äh da kritisiert wird, ist irgendwie dieses, dieser konkrete äh Peißen-Code, der äh von Netzentrypt halt noch mitgeliefert wird,
Gut,
kann man ja, kann man ja der Meinung sein, dass der, dass der irgendwie äh nicht optimal ist, aber das ist gar nicht der Punkt. Äh dass diese Installationssoftware, die sie da quasi, also diese Automatisierungssoftware ist halt und das sagt er auch,
In dem Talk, der äh äh Roland Schuhmaker, das ist im Prinzip so ein bisschen Proof of Concept,
weil wenn du halt ein Api lieferst und du hast äh ein ähm ne ein ein Protokoll basierte Interaktion mit der mit der Außenwelt,
kannst du nicht einfach nur die Backend Seite machen
du musst auch einen Client liefern, du musst es einfach, da musst du dein eigenes Hundefutter mal ordentlich in dich reinschütteln und ähm,
Es zeigt sich ja jetzt bereits, dass schon mit dem Start von Netz in Krypt,
viele alternative Implementierungen dieser kleinen Geschichte stattfinden. Und das ist ja sozusagen, das ist ja sozusagen nur Gaffer und Heißkleber, was sie da ausliefern. Es gibt jetzt schon diverse Webserverprojekte, die äh,
Dass quasi die Let's Ingrid Protokoll schon Bildin haben, hat dann auch äh ein schönes Beispiel genannt, ist ein Beispiel.
Und äh hat auch dann auch gesagt, es gibt Gespräche, zum Beispiel mit Engines,
und Dinge werden passieren und kommen und so und äh das ist das Einzige, was hier überhaupt relevant ist.
Ja teile ich. Ich sehe ich blicke gerade.
Ja, muss ja mal gesagt werden, weil es wird halt immer affig auf irgendwas eingeschlagen, äh von No Riesen und äh diese sogenannten Experten äh sollen sich mal ein bisschen an die Nase fassen.
Da besteht eben, genau, da da sind,
Leute sehr sympathisch, die ähm diese Protokolle dann oder die dieses Protokoll sich einfach mal angeschaut haben und andere Implementierungen gemacht haben. Das ist
von meiner Herangehensweise, ich habe mich damit jetzt
so das Peißen, als ich das mal irgendwie angefasst habe, war jetzt tatsächlich auch nicht so stabil. Und ähm ich war aber einfach sehr happy, wie einfach ich mir da ein signiertes Zertifikat äh holen konnte und ich habe diesen, ich meine, ich traue eh keiner Software, die jetzt meine Server einfach mal automatisch unkonfiguriert äh
Aber ne, wie gesagt, ich finde das, ich finde den Anspruch super und ähm den kann man verfolgen und das kann man auch dann besser machen, wenn einem das nicht.
Ja, das ist ein das ist eine eins null und wir werden dann zum nächsten Kongress äh schon mit einem ganz anderen Ist-Zustand äh leben. Interessant war auf jeden Fall mal die Zahl, dass jetzt schon die größte CA ist.
Ja, das ist, also ich habe mich mit mit dem Peter Eckersley mal äh längere Zeit unterhalten, der so den technischen Teil da mitgestaltet hat, ne.
Also so eine CA zu bauen, ja, das ist halt auch,
das ist kein Spaß. Und also die die Infrastruktur, die die da haben, ja, also allein um diese ganze Zeit das Ding signiert ja alle zwei Sekunden ein neues Zertifikat, ne? Und das diese,
diese ähm diese Frequenz wird noch massiv ansteigen, weil sie erstens sehr viel mehr Zertifikate rausgeben werden und zweitens ihr Anspruch ja ist, die Gültigkeitsdauer der Zertifikate immer kürzer zu machen.
Und die Server, sich einfach regelmäßig äh automatisiert neue Zertifikate holen zu lassen. Damit sollte,
damit halt der Aufwand ein Zertifikat zu brechen,
Ähm einfach für niemanden mehr interessant ist, ja? Also selbst wenn es irgendwann mal vielleicht rechnerisch,
irgendwo möglich wird oder wenn die NSA sehr viel mehr kann, als wir denken und irgendwie Kollisionen in den äh in den ähm
Hashtag Funktion findet und was nicht alles, dass sich der Aufwand einfach nicht mehr lohnt, weil dein Server andauernd, dass der Zertifikat automatisch erneuert. Und dafür brauchst du einfach eine Unmengen an Endropie
auf diesen Servern, die diese Zertifikate signieren wollen. Und da haben sie halt dann irgendwie so ähm,
Endropie, Hardware Security, Models und allen möglichen Mist aneinander geknotet. Die Dinger sind glühen, glühend heiß und so ein Ding irgendwie mal zu administrieren. Das ist schon echt ähm,
Schweißperlen auf der Stirn, wenn ich nur dran denke. Und das ist wirklich eine Wahnsinns Sache, die die ja geleistet haben. Ich wollte nur noch ganz kurz, weil ich hier so kurz auf meinen Bildschirm blickte und sah,
MLP, das war die Frau, die noch mit auf dem Wassener-Panel war und der sich da jetzt spontan ähm den Namen nicht wusste, ist mir peinlich.
Ciao.
Dann haben wir äh in unserer Reihe der schamlosen Selbstempfehlungen dann noch den Thomas.
Sind sie doch nicht wir selbst, ne? Das ist ja nur unsere Zuträger, unsere Wasserträger.
Nee, das nein, das finde ich, ich meinte jetzt eher so als äh als CCC und so weiter. Nein, Thomas Lohninger, selbstverständlich vor Ort, ähm zum Thema der Netzneutralität,
Hast du den Talk besuchen können? Ich habe eine Ausrede, da war nämlich gleichzeitig der Jahresrückblick, deswegen war ich nicht da.
Verstehe. Ich habe keine Ausrede.
Interessant, also ich war ich habe mir vorhin viel mit Thomas darüber gesprochen. Er fängt halt eben sein seinen Vortrag hatte, den Untertitel äh äh,
Was ja, glaube ich, heißt, äh der Würfel ist gefallen,
und das hat er dann feierlich direkt zu beginnen, weggestrichen und äh gezeigt, was jetzt zu tun ist.
Überhaupt nicht gefallen. Er fällt noch ein paar Mal. Ja, also er macht ja äh hat ein ein sehr, sehr, sehr positive Herangehensweise dadran und äh sagt eben, dass äh hier der Drops noch nicht gelutscht ist.
Ja, also auch auf jeden Fall natürlich.
Das hat er ja auch schon hier äh zum Besten gegeben und hier nochmal in Vortragsform. Genau. Das gucke ich mir auf jeden Fall auch nochmal an.
Dann für viele äh unserer äh Zuhörenden,
sicherlich sehr interessant und deswegen auch ein besonders hervorgehoben Netzpolitik in der Schweiz,
NDG Büpf und wie wir uns dagegen wehren. Ähm da hatten wir einmal so das der äh Netzaktivisten und Netzaktivistischen Vereinigungen,
der Schweiz auf der Bühne. Mhm. Ähm und zwar in Form von Vimia, Ari, Patrick Stellin und Hakuna Mamate. Ähm die dann eben über dieses das Nachrichtendienst Gesetz und die,
Herausforderungen in der Schweiz sprechen und ich hoffe, dass wir da den Kontakt aufrecht erhalten können, um dann hier auch regelmäßig,
schweizer Themen auch wieder im Logbuch Netzpolitik abdecken zu können.
Genau. So.
Ich sehe gerade die, die hatten Kathrin Rönicke als Harold. Die wurden also ganz vor ganz vorzüglich behandelt. Die können sich ja wohl über nichts beschweren.
Das war überhaupt ein Highlight, ne, mal so ganz nebenbei. Ähm auf diesem Kongress,
ich finde das immer so geil, wenn wenn der Club, also sagen wir mal, das komplette Kongressgeschehen, wenn sie festgestellt wird, dass irgendwas nicht so gut läuft,
Man sich so ein bisschen einig darüber ist, dass es nicht gut läuft. Denn wenn aber Maßnahmen ergriffen und dann wird's interessant.
Maßnahme ergreifen heißt, beim Camp im BER Village mal eine ordentliche, ausgedehnte, runde bestellen und sich zusammensetzen. Das war in dem Fall so.
Ah ja, okay, gut. Macht Sinn und hatte dann auch wohl den entsprechenden Effekt
diesmal eben wirklich ganz bewusst äh Leute
den man weiß, dass sie ähm ja wenig Probleme damit haben auf Dinge zu präsentieren oder zu moderieren, angesprochen wurden äh und äh damit wurde dann sozusagen auch die Tätigkeit des Harrols, also der der Ankündiger
etwas stärker definiert beziehungsweise von anderen Lasten,
befreit, dass man eben nicht mehr die komplette Raum Überwachung auch noch sozusagen, also die Raumüberwachung.
Betreuung heißt das.
Raumbetreuung, genau. Tschuldigung.
Überwachung auch noch.
Müssen wir auch noch alle überwachen hier. Ähm genau, also ich habe gerade nach dem korrekten Begriff gesucht dafür, Stage
Manager, genau. Also Stagemanagement wurde sozusagen von der Ankündigung äh getrennt und, und, und, und damit konnte man sich eben dann auch auf Leute fokussieren, die sehr viel mehr Spaß haben, äh Dinge anzukündigen. Und ich finde, das hat man gemerkt dieses Jahr, dass das sozusagen das Ganze
Ankündigungsbusiness da einfach äh lustiger und und und flüssiger äh ablief.
Es waren nicht nur ausgewählt, also es waren auch ausgewählte, ich meine, ist natürlich klar, wenn man sagt, wir wollen gute Harrits haben, dann,
werden natürlich auch Personen entsprechend angesprochen, aber der Lindform, unser Erzengel, für diese gesamte Sachen hat wirklich,
äh
quasi alle jede einzelne Bewerbung auf einen Posten als Harald Angel ähm mit einem, ich glaube, so halb bis einstündigen Skype Gespräch oder persönlichen Treffen ähm,
abgehandelt und dann da eben mit den Leuten äh mit den Leuten seine Auswahl getroffen.
Hat er gemacht.
Gecastet, ja. Man hat da auch ein sehr gutes Händchen bei bewiesen,
Was ja auch klar war. Ich meine, er macht seit Jahren äh Saal Saal eins in der Regel. Ähm,
und in als erfahrener Harold hat er da eben auch gewusst, was er den anderen Leuten sagen muss. Und das war eine Begegnung eben der Tatsache, dass er dass man,
vorher sich relativ einfach für diese Schichten melden konnte. Ein Tag vorher ein,
Allgemeines Training bekommen hat und er jetzt eben
eine Auswahl getroffen hat und nochmal so ein Vor Meeting und dann hat er alle nochmal einmal auf die Bühne geschickt und die irgendwas random ansagen lassen, glaube ich. Also er hat da, der hat ja richtig
richtig in die Schulung sein Herzblut investiert und das Ergebnis kann man echt sehen.
Und er hat irgendwie äh so ein so ein einfaches Problem gelöst, äh dass er dass er nochmal darauf geachtet hat, dass die Ansagen dann quasi so auf Schnittpausen achten,
Weil das eben dann auch wieder in der Koordination mit den Aufzeichnungen so problematisch war, dass man halt irgendwie vom Defragmentieren, also.
Orga Ansagen.
Ansagen und so, nicht nahtlos übergeht's zu einer Vorstellung eines Speakers und so und das jetzt haben wir auch die Ansagen, glaube ich, in so gut wie allen Aufzeichnungen drin.
So, heute geht's weiter.
Jetzt bin ich in der Schweiz hatten wir jetzt äh Afghane, ne, haben wir empfohlen,
Ähm. Ähm fand ich deshalb sehr ähm,
interessant, mal ein,
Wissenschaftler, der sich da dem äh Thema genäht hat, Christoph Engemann, der mir auch äh persönlich bekannt ist, der ich habe mal in einem dieser Bücher, die er herausgegeben hat, auch mal ein kleines Kapitel beigesteuert,
ähm und der hat sich halt damit auseinandergesetzt ähm,
welche ethischen und juristischen Implikationen dieser diese Drohnen,
Drohneneinsätze haben und dann äh welche Techniken sich dahinter verbergen und äh,
wie wie eben diese algorithmischen Entwicklungen zu bewerten sind, die das war eines der sage ich mal, einer der geheimen äh Schwerpunkte,
ähm in in im diesjährigen Kongressprogramm, nämlich sowas wie Algorithmenethik.
Und äh das haben glaube ich nur,
Nee, das haben zwei Leute wirklich äh gemerkt, das war einmal die die Redaktion vom NDR und einmal äh
der Thorsten Kleinst, der für ähm Heise darüber geschrieben hat. Äh und dieses Thema aufgegriffen haben, obwohl wir das jetzt nicht konkret ähm,
kommuniziert haben,
ähm und da da war eben äh Christoph Engemann, einer von und hat da äh einen Vortrag gehalten.
Und dieser Algorithmenethikvorträge haben natürlich immer auch so ein bisschen so einen größeren Blick auf die Dinge, ne? Deswegen sind die äh sehr schön.
Hatten wir da.
Die Kampagne haben wir ja hier äh ausführlich auch schon besprochen, als sie gelauncht ist, das Aussteigerprogramm für ähm,
mitarbeitende bei Geheimdiensten und äh hinter diesem Programm verbirgt sich ja das das
Kollektiv, was eigentlich eher für äh so Mediengerilla Aktionen bekannt ist. Ich glaube, sie selber präferieren den Begriff Culture Jaming und ähm,
Gloria Spindel hat da sehr schön auch über aus aus diesem Hintergrund,
über dieses über diese Aktion berichtet und von ihren von den Erfahrungen ist eine sehr gute Rednerin nebenbei auch nochmal,
Auf.
Ja, das ist, ich habe den nicht gesehen, aber ich habe aus den Reaktionen auf äh Twitter äh mitbekommen, dass ihr oft auftreten wohl sehr.
Das war sehr souverän. Ja, sehr, sehr souverän und ähm.
Positiv aufgenommen wurde. Ja. Und äh irgendjemand schrieb auch, er sei jetzt verliebt.
Das passiert regelmäßig auf Kongressen. Da müssen wir auch mal irgendwie gucken, wie wir das in den Griff krieg.
Ah
Du hast schon den nächsten rausgesucht. Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, was du dazu zu sagen hast.
Ja, Tennis, äh habe und äh Frank Rieger,
ähm wie der Titel schon sagt, vor zehn Jahren gab's halt einen Vortrag, eben dieses Titels und ähm das war ja damals wirklich ein,
das das war wirklich, wie sagt man, eine Zäsur? Also,
Die haben diesen Talk gemacht. Äh wichtiger war noch so ein bisschen der parallel publizierte äh Texte, etwas ähm stringenter natürlich rüberkamen, als äh dieser Talk letzten Endes. Trotzdem war einfach die Präsenz des Talks auf dem äh was war das dreiundzwanzig, zweiundzwanzig,
ähm zweiundzwanzig C drei,
Genau. Ähm ja, war so ein bisschen so ein Schock. Also man man merkte richtig äh den Reaktionen an, dass so,
Weißt du, ich meine, damals waren wir noch sehr euphorisch so, ne. Man wurde die ganze Zeit so gefeiert, ja hier, die Hacker, äh, kommen, wissen alles, machen alles kaputt, ne. Wir sind die Geilsten,
und ähm das wollen wir natürlich auch.
Wollte gerade sagen, hä?
Nur ihre These war halt, äh ja, vergesst es
die Geheimdienste haben gewonnen, die hören uns irgendwie überall ab und überhaupt und hinter den Kulissen geschehen Dinge, die wir noch gar nicht sehen und wir bräuchten jetzt mal äh ein paar Leute, die was liegen und,
Wenn man sich den Talk oder das Paper auch nochmal anschaut und dann unter dem Hintergrund vor dem Hintergrund, was jetzt in den letzten fünf Jahren so gelaufen ist,
muss man schon sagen, Hut ab, das war äh ein Stück Visionäre Darbietung. Und jetzt sind halt zehn Jahre rum,
Und sie haben jetzt quasi nochmal das Thema äh anders aufgegriffen, indem sie einerseits schon nochmal so eine so eine Analyse gemacht haben, State of the World, so was geht. Und das, was derzeit ja auch alles äh,
vergleichsweise bedrohlich wirkt. Andererseits aber, das fand ich wirklich 'n sehr interessanten Spin,
doch vor allem ein ein sehr optimistisches ähm,
auf auf konkrete Handlungsschritte ausgerichtetes Bild geliefert haben. Also im Kern würde ich das so zusammenfassen als.
Ja, die Dinge sind nicht so geil, wie wir sie gerne hätten, ja,
Aber es ist jetzt auch noch nicht alles verloren, beziehungsweise gibt's keine guten Gründe, äh die Flinte ins Korn zu werfen, sondern wir müssen uns jetzt einfach besser organisieren und,
glaube, das war so ein bisschen ihre Kernthese. Äh der Wunsch ähm dass die Szene sich einfach besser aufstellt
und sich auf ihre Stärken besinnt und eben versucht, diesen unvermeidlichen Prozess einfach äh so gut zu begleiten, wie es halt irgendwie geht. Und dass wir dabei auch noch eine Menge Spaß haben werden, nur dass die Welt nicht gleich morgen untergeht.
Ist ja auch mal was.
Es endete dann mit seinem großen Panoramabild vom Camp.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, äh hat auch den Begriff, der äh benutzt. Ich bin mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher, auf jeden Fall,
glaube ich, hat er da äh Bezug genommen ähm.
Ne?
Hakim Bay, das verlinken wir auch nochmal. The tempery, autonomes Zone und.
Von Hakim Bay. Ähm ich meine, da gab's Referenzen zu in dem Vortrag und wenn nicht, dann habe ich mir die einfach nur eingebildet und äh verlinke den diesen frei erhältlichen Text äh einfach trotzdem noch mal.
Ja, vielleicht ist ja Rob einfach nur das Camp zu äh zu Kopf gestiegen und hat sich hat sich wohl gefühlt.
Ich glaube, der hat sich da durchaus wohlgefühlt. Da gibt's keinen Zweifel.
Was man vielleicht den Unangeweiten auch nochmal äh an der Stelle vermitteln muss,
ist sicherlich nicht der die einzige Person, der man das zuschreiben kann, aber sicherlich die äh mit wichtigste äh Person, die daran ganz tatkräftig dazu beigetragen hat, dass es diese Campultur gibt.
Holland und die Hacker CRE Nummer.
Da hast du mich jetzt. Ja, genau, ich habe mit Rob mal ein sehr schönes Gespräch.
Eine der besten CAE-Episoden überhaupt.
In der Tat. Also, dass äh war eine dolle Sache,
CRE hundertzweiundsiebzig, da kann man vieles darüber erfahren. Ähm ja und Rob ist auch überhaupt eine sehr wichtige äh Person in unserer Hackergemeinde. Er hat ähm,
sehr viele Dinge angestoßen. Die Wahlcomputer äh Sache, das ist eigentlich im Wesentlichen seine Initiative gewesen und er hat ja dann den Kampf auch in Holland sehr erfolgreich.
Gefüttert, will ich jetzt nicht alles wiederholen, da könnt ihr wirklich mal den CRE reinhören
nur äh was damit unterstreichen möchte ist, dass äh dass ich der Rob auch persönlich äh sehr schätze und dass er einfach in den letzten zwanzig Jahren äh,
für die Bewegung einfach auch eine extrem wichtige Person war, oft hinter den Kulissen, nicht unbedingt immer so so sichtbar, wie wir jetzt bei diesen Talks. Ähm aber auf jeden Fall sehr wichtig.
Wenn er was macht, dann richtig.
Genau, also im Prinzip.
Und sei es nur mit einem verrückten Weißhaarigen in Island ein kleines Video von einem Hubschrauber editieren, äh was dann als College Mörder äh dann doch äh Geschichte schreibt, äh waren also ja.
Also so wie Wau Holland sozusagen prägend für für den die Kultur des Clubs in Deutschland war, so ist halt Rob äh in dieser Rolle nicht direkt vergleichbar, aber auf jeden Fall eine Dimension vergleichbar für die holländische Szene und ähm,
und mittlerweile eben auch für die Europäische und globale Szene. Jetzt aber genug beweihräuchert. Rob, ich hoffe, du hörst das jetzt.
Ja. Sorry Rob.
Uns leid. Aber muss ja mal gesagt werden.
Dann glaube ich, können wir nochmal einen kleinen äh ähm kleinen äh Abstecher in andere Tracks machen,
Joscha Bach, Computational Cology. Ähm der Josh hat sich ja jetzt auch so inzwischen, ich weiß gar nicht, wie war das jetzt dein dritter Vortrag zu dem Thema.
Mindestens. Zu dem Thema weiß ich nicht, aber es war mindestens sein dritter Talk auf Alpenkongress.
Ja
Ich finde aber nur, dann hat der wahrscheinlich die anderen unter seinem Pseudonym gehalten, ne. Wie dem wie auch immer, sage ich mal. Ähm,
Er ist einer, der glaube ich ähm.
Einflussreichen und bekannten äh Forschern zu künstlicher Intelligenz,
Und ähm was da was glaube ich bei bei ihnen zu einem,
unendlich spannenden Gesprächspartner und auch Vortragsredner macht, ist, dass er eben äh natürlich, wenn du wenn du künstliche Intelligenz machst, dann bist du hardcore,
Hardcore Programmierer und hast da irgendwie dein Themengebiet, aber er hat auch so eine äh philosophische sehr starke philosophische.
Reflektiert Halt,
Perspektive auf die Welt und das ein ist ja ein großartiger Redner und auch hier ein äh großartiger Vortrag zu dem man eigentlich auch gar nicht weiter kommentieren muss. Also,
Zu diesem Vortrag sind, finde ich, Kommentare weitgehend überflüssig.
Gut, das machen wir jetzt auch keine weiteren.
Wir kriegen nur noch den, wir kriechen jetzt nur noch den Leuten in den Arsch.
Wo sind wir?
Defen.
Selber nix kann.
Der Nordjahresrückblick ähm,
äh dieses Jahr äh parallel zu einer Veranstaltung von unseren Freunden von methodisch inkorrekt, was ähm auf beiden Sorten, auf beiden Seiten äh zu Verwirrungen,
führte und Unmut aber methodisch,
Ja, na ja, wir haben sie halt gegenseitig so ein bisschen gestichelt, dass sie sich natürlich jetzt die Zuschauer wegnehmen als als Highlights, als Highlight der Veranstaltung, aber ähm.
Äh Nikolaus und Reinhardt wollten ja nicht auf Tag eins Saal eins äh und mussten ja dann unbedingt auf äh Tag zwei,
äh
und da war aber Saal eins schon vergeben und deswegen kam sie in Saal zwei und dann kam die Feuerwehr und sagte, wat, Feuer, seid ihr wahnsinnig? Geht mal hin und sagt, geh und dann sind sie leider doch in einem kleinen Seil gelandet und wurden in den größeren Zahlen
gestreamt,
Und ich muss dann als äh mitwirkender in der Programmgestaltung doch entsetzt äh feststellen, dass ich dann wirklich zu sehr später äh
den Nikolaus mit seinem Kinderwagen gesehen habe und der war keine Kiste Bier drin, sondern ein Lebewesen und dann kreide ich das an
kreide ich an, dass er unter Vorspiegelung falscher Tatsachen offenbar äh an auf Tag zwei gehen wollte, obwohl sie äh von uns Tag eins äh angeboten bekommen.
Wie falscher Tatsachen.
Wenn ihr mir einen vom Schutz der Kinder erzählt, ne, und dann ist der da nachts um drei äh.
Quatsch, das war doch gar nicht der Grund.
Was denn? Also ich habe doch, ich habe doch hier die Mails bekommen.
Na, ich weiß ja nicht, was er dir geschrieben hat, aber äh der Grund war das, dass ich Tickstoff zu teuer, ja, ja.
Also der Stickstoff zu teuer anlieferbar, ja komm. Jetzt hier mit Geld kommen, weißt du? Ja, das sind doch Physiker, die verdienen sich doch die.
Die Nase goldig.
Und die hat ja genau.
Genau, das war dann, das war, glaube ich, dann so der Tag zwei war dann so der der Unterhaltungshighlight-Tag. Äh es gibt Jahresrückblick hat eine große Fangemeinde und äh methodische inkorrekt auch und das war dann so der beide äh man konnte eben nicht beide gleichzeitig schauen und muss sich jetzt einen
von beiden im auf Media CC D E anschauen.
Ja, also die Wahl ist leicht. Meine klare Empfehlung äh ist methodisch inkorrekt. Ich war, warst du, hast du's gesehen?
Ich habe natürlich beides gesehen, selbstverständlich.
Live. Ach so, bis dahin.
Kann ja nur eins von bei ihm live schauen.
Wie auch immer, ich äh äh war äh vor Ort und äh es war,
Grandiose Show. Also es war einfach toll und zwar äh nicht nur von dem, was geboten wurde, sondern von dem, was auch sagen wir mal so äh die Zuschauer geleistet haben. Da war einfach eine Bombenstimmung
und ähm Gott sei Dank hat die Aufzeichnung geklappt. Es gab da noch so ein paar Schwierigkeiten. Das Wort hat sich da schwer ins Zeug gelegt, um die Aufnahme zu retten.
Also da wurde so richtig noch so von Hand nachgeschnitten und so weiter, um äh sozusagen eine korrekte Aufzeichnung zu liefern
Das wär's natürlich jetzt gewesen nach dem ausgefallenen Camp jetzt sozusagen auch noch das Ding nicht als Aufzeichnung liefern zu können, das wäre wirklich hart gewesen, aber soweit ist es nicht gekommen. Von daher
alles supi äh betonisch inkorrekt auf jeden Fall äh ein Highlight werde ich das Show-Highlight des Kongresses.
Ja, wir waren's auf jeden Fall nicht. Das kann man das.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, auf keinen Fall.
Dann müssen wir jetzt hier mal weiterschauen. Also äh State of the Onion ähm kann man, glaube ich, äh getrost eben unter ähm,
Klassiker und für Interessierte natürlich auch ein Mastziehverbuchen, brauchen wir aber jetzt auch inhaltlich nicht weiter drauf einzugehen.
Also Tor.
Genau, da haben wir dann äh diesmal mit mit natürlich wieder Roger Dinge dein und Apple-Baum. Ähm Mike Perry, äh dem Entwickler des Tor Browser,
und der jetzt grade äh die ähm die die Torchefin geworden ist,
langjährige IFF ähm Veteranen, die äh jetzt das das Torprojekt ähm vertreten wird,
und Alison McQueen, die, wenn ich mich jetzt korrekt erinnere, ähm,
da einen äh Kurzauftritt hatte, wo es um das um Tor und das Engagement einer öffentlichen Bibliothek in den USA ging.
Da haben wir also einmal äh groß aufgefahren. Dann haben wir hier einen Talk, den würde ich
Grundsätzlich gerne empfehlen, muss aber zugeben, dass der bis jetzt noch nicht zu mir durchgedrungen ist auf meiner äh Liste. Äh das ist Lessons learnd, Freifunk für Geflüchtete. Wir hatten das ja hier auch schon mehrmals,
ähm gelobt und erwähnt, dass ähm sehr, sehr viele, wenn nicht so gut wie alle ähm,
Unterkünfte, die äh Geflüchteten angeboten werden ähm,
Beziehungsweise, wo sie gezwungen sind, sich drinnen aufzuhalten, äh mit Internet versorgt sind. Und ähm es gibt da eine sehr,
aktive Community aus dem Freifunkbereich, die sagt, wieder gibt's kein Internet, geht ja gar nicht. Dann machen wir da jetzt Internet hin. Und das ist wirklich ähm.
Irre, die müssten bald um die einhundert Unterkünfte in Deutschland mit äh freien Wählern versorgt haben. Das ist schon,
Wahnsinnseinsatz dieser Community, die eben da auch einfach äh genau,
Also das trifft halt so vieles, ja. Also ich meine, diese frei von Community haben jetzt seit seit so langem, ja? Und die haben so viel Expertise und so viel ehrenamtlichen Taten dran,
und in so einer Situation sind die natürlich dann auch zur Stelle. Ähm.
Ja und das hat auch, glaube ich, dem Projekt selber mal wieder äh eine eine klare,
einer Bedeutung eingehaucht ist jetzt ein bisschen die falsche Formulierung, ne, was ich habe gesehen, gemerkt und gefühlt, dass äh ähm,
das Projekt selber gemerkt hat, dass sie jetzt hier mal wieder ein Thema gefunden haben, wo sie ihre komplette Kompetenz einfach mal bestmöglich,
einbringen können. So, wo wirklich all das zusammenkommt, obwohl man ja nicht sagen kann, dass das jetzt von Anfang an das Ziel gewesen wäre.
Nee, mein, also sie haben halt, sie haben halt einfach mal wieder ein ein wie kann man das sagen, hm ein öffentlich,
wahrgenommenes und relevantes Thema, wo sie ihre einzigartige Bedeutung und ihre Begeisterung vermitteln können,
So in einer Welt, in der irgendwie äh Kabel Deutschland diese komischen Hotspot-Angebote rausballert und man mit Störerhaftungen auch das letzte offene WLAN irgendwie äh wegknallen möchte,
treten eben frei Funker auf und zeigen, warum sie das alles seit Jahren machen. Und haben ein sehr schönes Beispiel. Die hatten, glaube ich,
in den letzten Jahren in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung immer mehr Schwierigkeiten halt auch ihre ihre Ideale einfach mal in einem einfachen Punkt, einem einfachen Beispiel zu vermitteln.
Und ich glaube nicht, das muss ich vielleicht noch dazu sagen,
in keiner Form machen sie diese Aktion, um jetzt irgendwie ihre Ideale öffentlich zu vermitteln, weil ich habe echt Schwierigkeiten gehabt, mal herauszufinden, wo das überhaupt alles stattfindet, ja. Da hast du viele, viele äh Unterkünfte, wo irgendwie,
Kein Mensch jemals drüber gesprochen hat, was da geleistet wurde, sondern einfach gemacht wurde. Wahnsinn.
Dann kommen wir zu einem Talk, der äh ja, an der, an der harten Grenze des Kontroversen äh ist, was die Speaker angeht,
Und zwar ist das von äh. Ähm,
Ist eine Vereinigung aus den USA von ähm im Prinzip könnte man sagen Opfern,
Krieg äh habe ich jetzt USA gesagt, UK, Entschuldigung, eine Vereinigung aus den UK. Ähm,
von Opfern und Betroffenen des War on Terra. Und der äh.
Der Vorsitzende ist auch ein äh ehemaliger ähm Guantanamo-Häftling, der da äh,
unschuldig festgehalten wurde. Und äh sie leiden natürlich unter andauernder äh Belästigung, wenn sie irgendwie in die Nähe eines Flughafens kommen und so. Entsprechend ähm,
Ist aber auch ihr Äußeres, ne? Haben alle sehr äh sehr, sehr ausgeprägte, kleidvolle, gepflegte Bärte und auch entsprechende Kleidung. Und ähm,
Wir haben diesen Talk deshalb im Programm, um mal zu zeigen, wie eben ja, Menschen, die,
von ihrem Äußeren und auch von ihrem Glauben her eben bestimmte Klischees erfüllen. Ähm unter diesen dieser Diskriminierenden Praxis des Kriegs gegen den Terror äh täglich leiden.
Das äh war, glaube ich, sehr eindrücklich und man findet keine anderen,
Person, die da so eindrückliche und so ausführliche Erfahrungen haben. Entsprechend hat äh dann auch äh diesen Talk äh Jacob Apple-Baum als Ansager, der,
bis zum bis zum Ende der Veranstaltung auf der Bühne geblieben ist, begleitet.
Mhm.
Weil sie natürlich dann auch über diese ganzen äh Liberation äh Technologies und so was gesprochen haben,
Man kann aber an der Stelle,
auch nicht verschweigen, dass in anderen politischen Bereichen, die nicht die äh Überwachung und den Krieg gegen den Terror und die Kollateralschäden des Krieg gegen den Terror angehen
einige Mitglieder von Kage durchaus mal Positionen vertreten, die nicht unbedingt mit ähm den Idealen des Chaos-Computerclub einhergehen,
und äh dafür haben wir dann natürlich auch äh dazu haben wir auch Feedback bekommen. Ähm,
Denke, da sind wir an einem Bereich oder in einem Bereich, wo wir eben sagen, dazu haben sie auch nicht gesprochen, das war auch nicht Thema des Talks und der Talk als solcher war eindrücklich, aber,
Wie gesagt, wir waren am äußeren Ende der kontroversen Skala mit einigen, der dort äh,
Derjenigen, die dort gesprochen haben, denke aber die Inhalte des Talks sind in keiner Form äh besonders kontrovers.
Eine Gradwanderung.
Ja muss dann vielleicht auch dazugeben, dass wir jetzt nicht,
Bei jedem Speaker den vollständigen Backgroundcheck, was er in jedem TV-Interview irgendwann mal im Nebensatz gesagt hat, gemacht haben,
Aber wichtig für uns, diese Perspektiven ähm einzubringen und eben auch insbesondere in diesem Bereich Menschen eine Stimme zu geben, die deren Stimme nicht unbedingt gehört wird, ja? Die können sich den Mund fusselig reden.
Und wenn du die leiden natürlich dann auch eben unter den äh Vorurteilen, die gegen die unsere Gesellschaften, gegenüber gegenüber ihrem Äußeren unweigerlich inzwischen haben, kannst du dich gar nicht mehr gegen wehren, auch ich nicht.
Max Sims hat mal eingeladen. Das hat mich ja gefreut, dass das geklappt hat. Ähm,
Auch einer der, ich glaube, einer der am besten bewerteten Talks von diesem Kongress. Daran hatte ich keinen Zweifel, aber äh kann man natürlich auch nochmal erwähnen,
ähm allen bekannt als der österreichische Jurastudent, der mal nebenbei den äh,
das Safehaber-Abkommen zu Fall gebracht hat
Und äh den Anwälten von Facebook seit längerer Zeit ein unangenehmer Schmerz im Arsch ist. Äh inzwischen hat er mir dann so erzählt, dass ihr zu allem möglichen äh Großkanzleien irgendwie quasi
ähm ihn ansprechen und äh,
Ich weiß nicht, aus also es ist natürlich klar, dass jemand, der aus dem Nichts so einen so einen Wind macht natürlich auch äh entsprechende,
Angebote von Kanzleien kriegt, die davon leben, Wind zu machen, aber natürlich glaube ich auch teilweise von Könzlein, die davon leben, dass kein Wind entsteht.
Und äh erstaunlich, aber da muss ich echt sagen, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das überhaupt schon mal öffentlich gesagt hat, aber der verfolgt also überhaupt gar keine äh Ambitionen jetzt irgendwie Anwalt zu werden. Äh was ja unter anderem
einer der äh auch so ein Argument war, was diese Facebook-Juristen dann irgendwann mal äh gegen ihn angebracht haben.
Interesse und so.
Ja Eigeninteresse, kommerzielles Interesse der der vermarktet sich doch nur selber indem er in dem
diese Regulation zu Fall bringt. Max, cooler Typ und äh super Vortrag äh auch so ein ja klares äh,
muss man, muss man sehen, Ding.
Genau, bis verpasst hat, war hier dann auch zu Gast in LNP hundertfünfundfünfzig.
Genau, da konnte ich, glaube ich, leider nicht dabei sein, oder?
Das war dann mit Thomas noch mit dabei und da haben wir uns dann ausführlich über diesen ganzen Safehaberkram. Aus unserer Perspektive schon unterhalten und jetzt das Ganze halt nochmal in Vortragsform auf den Kongress.
Ich muss.
Ja, nur also am Rande erwähnt, äh Andreas Davis, Sai to you new boss. Auch äh ein Vortrag aus dieser,
ähm aus der Algorithmenethik ähm.
Der, den ich auch noch auf meiner Liste habe zum Schauen, aber von dem ich auch schon sehr viel äh Interessantes äh Feedback gehört habe, den ich deshalb hier auch erwähne. Hasse Steini gesehen, der kommt ja gerade. Ja,
eine ein Vortrag äh den man auch, der ist unbeschreiblich und sei an dieser Stelle auch äh empfohlen. Quantenphysik und Kosmologie auch einfach ein ähm.
Naturtalent,
an Vortragen da ohne irgendwelche Folien da sich in den Saal gesetzt und mal spontan so ein bisschen geredet in mit einem Humor und einer.
Ja, der Typ ist einfach cool. Also das ist einfach äh.
Hat auch äh enormes äh Feedback bekommen und eben auch äh leider einer der äh Vorträge, die,
Äh wo wir eine massive Unterschätzung äh einer massiven Unterschätzung des Interesses auferlegen sind
der musste in Saal sechs vortragen, wo du irgendwie so ein paar hundert Sitze hast,
Und der hat jetzt irgendwie äh zweihundertsiebenunddreißigtausend Klicks auf Media CCC DE in der ersten Januarwoche,
Also ich glaube so.
Äh
Ja, das äh ja.
So wie spontan sehe ich da jetzt nur Max, der jetzt bald die halbe Million äh knackt? Ähm ja ja.
Echt. Krass.
Also da ähm.
Schaut sich auch echt jemand an, ne, was wir da machen, ist echt krass.
Das schauen sich auch Leute an. Ja, also äh,
Sorry. Andererseits würde ich jetzt zum Wohle des Teams irgendwie sagen, naja, aber er hat auch eben so seinen Vortragsart und sein Style und sein so mal,
Haben sie sich so aufm aufm Tisch sitzt, im Schneidersitz und irgendwie aus dem Nähkästchen plaudert, das passt ja auch ganz gut in so einen kleinen Saal.
Wahnsinn, Wahnsinnsvortrag, super unterhaltsam und ähm,
Ja, der könnte so äh locker mal äh Gast in den verschiedenen äh Physik äh Quantenphysik und Kosmologie-Podcasts äh unseres Planetensystems werden.
Harald Lesch muss sich warm anziehen.
Ja.
Ach ja.
Ist ja auch von Anfang an bei Chaos-Radio mit dabei gewesen, Steini.
Ja und da auch mit ähnlicher.
Ja, er war immer, war immer lustig, so.
Ich würde das jetzt, ich habe tausend Zitate aus diesem Vorteil gekauft, aber der Kammer, der Mann ist nicht zu imitieren. Ähm.
So dann überspringe ich jetzt glücklicherweise so ein paar Vorträge, die ich nicht ähm die ich noch nicht gesehen habe. Ähm,
oder erwähne sie nur kurz, weil wir weil ich in meiner Playlist noch nicht so weit bin, ähm.
Wir müssen ja auch mal durchkoppieren.
Man kann doch hier Skype drücken. Fertig, wir reden jetzt hier. Äh.
Darauf mache ich mir jetzt keine Sorgen.
Äh wie Jugendschutzprogramme, nicht nur die Jugend schädigen von Alver Freude, der sich ja seit langer Zeit mit solchen äh Sachen auseinandersetzt. AK ähm
Zensur ähm
seine Diplomarbeit oder was das war, Masterabschlussarbeit irgendwie auch zu diesen Themen Content-Filtern geschrieben und behandelt jetzt eben äh auch seit längerer Zeit Jugendschutzprogramme immer auch den Jugendmedien,
Staatsvertrag und so, dass es so das Thema mit dem Eiweiß sich auseinandersetzt und hier auch, dass er auch hier in diesem Vortrag behandelt hat,
Dann gab's ein äh.
Und äh vor allem.
Haha.
Noch gar nicht gesehen, ne.
Nicht gesehen.
Genau, also äh ich habe
ich habe ihn auch nicht gesehen, ich habe jetzt nur äh gesehen, dass es äh Reaktionen gab, aber äh Inreaktionen dadrauf hat die Deutsche Telekom bereits äh Änderungen angekündigt, von äh der Kinderschutzkoffe, die
vermutlich, so nehme ich an, sonst macht's keinen Sinn. Äh hier auch in der Kritik stand und äh von daher merkt man,
Es wird schon zugeschaut.
Es wird zugeschaut.
Und und nicht nur von den Convotet, ja.
Ah, die Telekom ist auch auf dem besten Wege.
Wir verlinken das einfach mal ganz äh unwissend über die genaueren äh Details, aber äh hatte wohl schon Nachwirkungen.
Ah, ich ich nehme jetzt mal gar nichts aus dem Security-Track, aber es gibt natürlich einige im im Security-Bereich, die ich auch empfehlen würde, aber die,
man dann auch selber ähm,
MC
der hat auch sehr, sehr gutes Feedback und noch gar nicht so viele Klicks auf Media CCD. Ähm die,
ähm oder das Team von Transparency Tool Kit, das sich so um MC gesammelt hat ähm.
Scrapt so Daten aus sozialen Netzen und baut dann da so eine eigene Datenbank draus,
alles mit Open-Source Tools und so. Und der hat dann so Scherze gemacht wie,
mal die die Mitglieder der Intelligence-Community so auf ähm LinkedIn sich rauszuscraben,
und dann Daten zu denen zu sammeln und äh so soziale Geflechte und so weiter.
Dann dort äh zu visualisieren. Der hat so eine Mischung aus einerseits eben Massendatenanalysen, äh,
Netzwerkanalysen und eben auch ähm,
ganz lustigen äh Herausstellungen von Individuen, die er da junge Mann ist echt ein junger Mann mit äh beachtlichen ähm,
beachtlichen Erfolgen schon so in seinem Leben und das ist echt mal äh spannend, den zu sehen. Nicht ähm,
Nicht zu verschweigen ist eben auch, was ihn, was ihm und seinen Mitstreitern dieses Projekt schon inzwischen an äh Bedrohungen und Gegenwind ähm eingebracht hat. Äh das ist auch äh beachtlich.
Kann man sich vorstellen.
Jetzt habe ich hier meinen Scrollfaden verloren. Du nicht.
Ja, ich nicht. Ja, Gunnar Tölle war dann noch ganz äh informativ, halbe Stunde Talk über Stromtankstellen,
Was ich schon allein deshalb bemerkenswert fand, einfach, weil das Thema dann einfach mal auch so auf den Kongress landet. Das finde ich halt gut. War jetzt nicht ähm.
Also er er hat es jetzt nicht zu sehr auseinandergenommen alles technisch, aber er hat sozusagen einfach mal vorgestellt, was was gibt's eigentlich, was äh was fahren die äh Stromtankstellen heutzutage für,
Kolle, was für ein Desaster ist äh der ganze Payment-Bereich. Was, was, was kann man mit manchen Stromtaktstellen machen und auch sehr schön,
Er hat dann einfach seinem äh Vortrag, wo er dann teilweise etwas durchhetzen musste, aber
der wenigen Zeit, aber er hat dann sozusagen, weil Leute nicht wissen, wie Stromtankstellen aussehen, sehr viele Fotos von Stromtankstellen in aller, in allen Formen, Farben, Varianten und Orten äh immer noch mal so zwischen seines Leids gepackt, das fand ich irgendwie eine sehr gute Idee.
Aber sehr viel äh,
Basis geliefert, um mal sich sozusagen des Themas anzunehmen. Also so ein klassischer Early-Adopter-Talk, so wie ein Steini übrigens auch vor, weiß nicht, glaube ich, mittlerweile auch zehn Jahren oder so, mal gehalten hat über Drohnen,
Er meinte so, das kommt jetzt und hat sich damit so beschäftigt und hat da einfach mal einen Talk über Drohnen gemacht,
und er hätte nicht Rechte haben können sein können. Also es war einfach,
der richtige Punkt so und äh danach passierte einfach enorm viel und ich denke auch diese ganze Elektromobilität,
äh ist genauso ein Thema
Ja und äh der Titel sagt es schon, Stromtankstellen, eine neue öffentliche Infrastruktur, das ist halt einfach etwas, was man sich anschauen muss und was sich mit dem ja sicherlich noch eine Menge Spaß haben.
Der von dir erwähnte Talk von Steini ist Drohnen und Quattrocopter Camp zweitausendsieben.
Nee, es war ein Kongresst-Talk. Also, das war ein Kongresst-Talk und das ist, glaube ich, schon noch länger her.
Noch länger. Ah, du meinst, beim dreiundzwanzig zu drei.
Äh müssen wir jetzt beide verlinken, ne? Mist. Okay.
Sorry.
So, was haben wir denn noch? Ähm,
Jahr Jahresrückblick hatten wir ähm hatten wir erwähnt, gab's ähm muss man jetzt nicht sehen als Logbuch Netzpolitik Hörer hat man das ja alles übers Jahr schon eh.
Ja gut, ich meine, es gibt natürlich hier nochmal eine spezifische ähm,
Sichtweise ist ja nicht nur Jahresrückblick vom CCC über alle Themen, sondern eben auch Themen, die den,
Club jetzt auch speziell tangiert haben oder wo der Club in irgendeiner Form öffentlich auch aktiv geworden ist oder eine Rolle gespielt hat. Von daher ist das ja an sich ein sehr schönes ähm,
Standardformat des Kongresses. Finde ich wichtig, weil man darüber einfach auch ein bisschen Einblick bekommt in was macht denn dieser Club eigentlich so?
Ja
Von dem man immer so viel hört.
Mhm. Dann ah, jetzt kommen ja echt Inkorrekt hatten wir. Ähm.
Die szenische Lesung, Grundrechte gelten nicht im Weltall hatten wir auch schon erwähnt, ne?
Nebenbei so.
Nebenbei erwähnt. Also auch ganz ähm amüsant.
Und äh empfohlen. Leider bei mir in der Playlist bisher immer so am Ende des Tages gewesen sind, dass ich die jetzt schon äh zweimal angefangen habe, aber es war quasi vorgesehen, dass ich dabei einschlafe und nicht,
dem Inhalten der Lesung geschuldet. Glaube das ist sehr äh sehr schön, mal also die die Menge an Protokollen, die jetzt irgendwie von Netzpolitik org da angefertigt wurden, ähm,
Das sind so viele Seiten und diese die Inhalte dieses äh Untersuchungsausschusses sind so viele Inhalte und da mal von den,
Von der Redaktion ausgewählt, die skurrilsten Stellen dann in so einer szenischen Lesung zu haben, äh besser kann man die Skurrilität auch glaube ich gar nicht äh dort ähm zeigen,
Da war übrigens auch äh der Felix Betzin dabei und der Zebas, die ja den geneigten, hörenden auch aus dem äh Podcast technische Aufklärung bekannt sind.
Genau.
Und Konstanze kurz und Annabiselli.
Arne Semsrott hat einen sehr äh unterhaltsamen Vortrag gehalten. Das ist ja auch schon fast so ein das ist auch inzwischen echt so ein Kongressklassiker Informationsfreiheitsgesetz äh Vorträge und frage den Staatvorträge,
aber da haben wir uns auch dieses Jahr nicht durchringen können, dass nicht ins Programm zu nehmen.
Weil mit Arne immerhin jetzt ein anderer Vertreter da ist und jemand, der auch einfach sehr äh amüsant vorträgt und der auch noch ein neues Projekt äh vorstellen konnte, nämlich äh sie haben ja einmal äh frag den Staat und
auf die Antworten, die sie bei oder die Antworten und nicht Antworten, die sie bei,
Frag den Staat bekommen. Äh folgt eben auch sehr häufig, verklagt den Staat. Und deswegen, ja, sind,
eine zweite äh Plattform äh geöffnet. Krypto ist Abwehr, IFG ist Angriff, eine Unterhalts.
Auch so die Plattform verklagt den Staat.
Ja aber sicher, wie soll denn sonst heißen?
Ja, sehr schön. Ich hatte das noch gar nicht gesehen.
Oder habe ich das jetzt sage ich jetzt verklagt den Staat DE oder nicht?
In der Tat grandios. Oh weiali.
Ja, also ein auch ein Garant für ähm.
Fortgesetzten Spaß.
Für fortgesetzten Spaß.
Dann gab's übrigens noch äh hier How Opens for Software Secondhand Laptops and Hackers, stop Ebola. Ähm.
Einen Vortrag unterer widrigen Bedingungen, weil wir aufgrund von äh Visa Problemen nicht alle ähm Vortragenden vor Ort haben konnten, eher sogar nur einen kleinen Teil, der Vortragenden.
Aber da sieht man halt auch mal, äh da sieht man halt ad hoc Engagement, äh,
freie äh freier Zugang zu wissen, wie da halt irgendwie in kürzester Zeit im im in Anbetracht der drohenden, nahenden Apokalypse ähm,
Engagement gezeigt wurde, eine Stunde, die auch einfach mal äh Horizont erweiternd ist.
Und übrigens auch wieder einen hervorragenden Vortragenden. Das ist auch so eine Sache, die mir jetzt immer, also da hm achte ich natürlich grundsätzlich sowieso so ein bisschen drauf, ähm,
aber die mir irgendwie nochmal mehr bewusst geworden ist, es gibt es gibt schlechte Vorteile, es gibt,
Vortragende, es gibt gute Vortragende und es gibt exzellente Vortragende. Das ist echt nochmal, da muss man wirklich sagen, da gibt's nochmal so eine noch mal so eine Kategorie exzellente Vortragende.
Hatten wir ein paar von.
Da hatten wir ein paar von, ja.
Ja fast, ich vermisse einen Talk, ja.
Kannst ja nochmal einen Rücksuch suchen. Ich könnte noch pluggen, weil's einfach immer so schön ist,
das ist dann immer kurz vor knapp, ganz am Ende die wunderbare Zusammenfassung der gesamten Netzwerkstatistiken,
Das schließt halt das äh die Arbeit des ein, also das eigentliche IP-Netzwerk, das äh GSM äh und Telefonnetzwerk
und auch die Seidenstraße äh konnte sich diesmal nochmal präsentieren, die fand ich ja ziemlich gelungen dieses Jahr.
Seidenstraße, das muss ich ja kurz erzählen. Ich habe ähm ich habe mich hier vor ein paar Tagen mit einem äh Journalisten unterhalten, ähm der bisher weder beim Kongress, noch beim Camp war.
Mhm. Solche Journalisten gibt's.
Ja und dann erwähnten wir irgendwie so, wollten irgendwie wie so den Zauber des Kongresses und der Camps näher bringen und haben dann die Seidenstraße erklärt, die Seidenstraße ist ja das Rohrpostsystem,
des äh des CC. Und er sagte irgendwie nur so, ah Internet of Things.
Das trifft's allerdings ganz gut.
Das trifft es so.
Der Mann hatte Humor und ist herzlich gebeten, sich doch bitte zum nächsten Kongress zu akkreditieren.
So
Dann der Talk, den ich noch vergessen habe, der mir irgendwie gerade überflogen ist,
Ähm nationale Souveränität ist ja jetzt nicht unbedingt eines der Kernanliegen des Chaos Computerclubs
Ähm aber wir haben hier einen äh palästinensischen ähm,
Arzt, der äh dadurch bekannt geworden ist, dass er ähm einen 3D-Drucker äh.
Anwendet, um ähm zum Beispiel, das hat ihn, glaube ich, sehr bekannt gemacht, so ein äh Stetoskop zu machen,
Stehtus, guck, diese einmal tief einatmen, diese kalten Dinger, die dann an den Rücken gehalten kriegst, ne? Äh so und der hat der hat so ein Ding in drei D gedruckt, entwickelt und,
irgendwie alle,
Tests zeigen, dass das irgendwie besser ist, ist als das Paar hundert Euro Konkurrenzprodukt eines kommerziellen Anbieters. Und ähm ja, er spricht eben da über äh die Rolle von freier Software und freier Hardware in Gaza
Und das ist natürlich auch mal echt,
eine eine krasse, krasser Themenbereich. So also das ist auch wieder so einer von denen, wo ich sage so, ey, da wird mal.
War das in deinem.
Ieve erweitert. Das war in meinem Track, ja.
Kannst du mir sagen, wie bitte diese Leute und Themen zum Kongress kommen.
Was sind diese Leute?
Okay. Was mich jetzt hier,
was ich feststelle dieses Jahr ist, dass wir einen deutlich höheren Anteil haben an Speakern, die nicht so aus der klassischen westlichen Luxuswelt kommen.
Und auch entsprechende Themen. Ich meine, was das Ebola Beispiel gebracht, Gaza, ähm, et cetera. Also, ich finde es gut,
Äh frage mich nur, ist das mehr durch Ansprache? Ist er sozusagen eine aktive Recherche äh dahinter gewesen oder ist es tatsächlich so, dass dass das bei uns aufläuft mittlerweile?
Also das läuft auf. Äh also erstens würde ich mal sagen, jemand der mit freier Software und freier Hardware äh agiert, ist ja wohl eindeutig mal einer von uns. Und äh Tarek Lubani hat eingereicht. War ein ganz normaler Einreicher.
Ähm das andere Beispiel, was du hattest, war Ebola, das war eine Einladung,
Aus dem, aus dem Kreis des Kontinents, sogar noch nicht mal aus dem Track Politik, in dem es am Ende stattgefunden hat und die Cage-Leute, die du jetzt ansprachst, waren, äh, haben eingereicht, allerdings auf,
Anraten eines langjährigen Kongressbesuchers. Da gab's also so, ja, uns wurde gesagt, wir sollen hier mal einreichen,
Und wen hatten wir noch? Was so, ja, Keynote war eingeladen. Hm.
Mehr fällt mir jetzt gerade nicht ein. Vielleicht gab's ja noch ein paar Sachen, die wir nicht erwähnt haben. Nee, war jetzt nur mal so äh als allgemeiner Hintergrund. Ähm also es ist eine Mischung aus allem.
Und äh Tarek eben auch ein äh auch ein ein einfach ein guter Vortragener, der wenn nicht sogar ein exzellenter Vortrag.
Ja, ich finde das gut, weil wir sind natürlich auch, also bestimmte Bereiche, ich meine, wir hatten da noch so zwei äh,
Koreaner, die äh zum haben wir jetzt grad gar nicht erwähnt, auch Security können wir vielleicht später auch nochmal drüber sprechen, also die haben ja so über Voiceover IP äh bisschen.
Also über Voice over LTE.
Also genau, also Voice genau, also Voice über LTE, was auch was oder P ist richtig und ähm.
Korea, also Asien ist bisher wenig bis gar nicht vertreten gewesen. Ich spüre einfach, wie dieser Kongress langsam,
seine Internationalität noch mehr ausweitet. Und das äh ist gut.
Gut, dann bin ich aber beruhigt.
Ja. Wollte ich nicht verunsichern.
Ja die Frage klang am Anfang so ein bisschen.
Mich hat das nur interessiert, wie da jetzt so die Dynamiken sind, weil wenn man jetzt nicht selber im Content Team ist, dann äh weiß man das halt nicht so ganz genau, ne, was was da sozusagen im Hintergrund äh immer die Vorgeschichte war.
Ja, also das,
Wir müssen jetzt vielleicht zu diesem Content-Team nochmal. Wir müssen jetzt sagen, so, wir haben jetzt eine kleine Auswahl gegeben und ich kann mir schon vorstellen, wie viele äh uns jetzt inzwischen schon gar nicht mehr zuhören oder halt,
auf dem Weg ins Krankenhaus sind, weil ihre Ohren bluten. Ähm,
Das war jetzt eine kleine subjektive Auswahl von zwei Personen, die mal so ein bisschen das muss man schon mal erwähnen,
in hauptsächlich Politik äh genommen haben. Wir haben nochmal mindestens genauso viel in äh Security und ähm,
Dann eben nochmal, wie zahlenmäßig einfach weniger vertreten ähm in ähm,
Hardware und Faillosophie,
Insofern da gibt's eine da gibt's halt einfach ein ein unglaublich reichhaltiges Programm und diesen,
Ich weiß nicht genau, wie weit über einhundert Vorträgen stehen eben auch nochmal viele hundert gegenüber, die nicht angenommen wurden. Und die sind teilweise mindestens genauso gut. Ja, also das äh diese.
Könnte man eigentlich alle drei Monate machen, ne?
Ja, also es ist dann auch es ist dann eben auch wirklich absurd, dass du dass du bestimmte, dass du bestimmte Talks ablehnst, wo du denkst, das hättest du ja nie vorstellen können, dass dass du irgendwann mal,
Diese Person mit diesem Vortrag ablehnst als kleiner Wicht. Ja, das ist äh es ist schon echt ähm,
Schon immer sehr, sehr, sehr ähm schmerzhaft sich da ins ins eigene Fleisch zu schneiden.
Müssen wir irgendwann mal zwei Kongresse im Jahr machen.
Ja oder jedes Jahr Camp oder so. Ja, vielleicht machen wir jetzt auch erstmal nichts mehr, weil mir ey, war schon ein bisschen anstrengend auch gewesen.
Wie gesagt, wer nach Silvester werden auch Silvester gefeiert hat, hat was falsch.
Tja, jetzt machen können wie ich, ne. Ich habe mir da.
Euer eigenes Sendezentrum hingestellt,
weiß ich nicht wie viele freiwillige Helfer das Sendezentrum dieses Jahr da getragen haben, das ist schon enorm auch, ne, also was da an.
Ja, also wir haben ja so ein Kernteam von vier Leuten, die das so planen und dann vor Ort gab's noch ähm,
jetzt nicht so richtig durchgezählt. Nochmal so drei, vier Leute, die dazugestoßen sind und da sehr viel äh gerissen haben, insbesondere dieser Podcaster-Tisch wurde dahinten nochmal,
bespielt. Ähm wir hatten diesmal auch ähm Unterstützung durch Engel,
Das hat geholfen. Ähm ja, überhaupt wird das gut angenommen. Also.
Ja, das ist.
Zentrum war schick.
Wer, wer sind denn die die Kernorgale, die kann man nämlich auch mal.
Ja, also das ist äh vor allem Ralf Stockmann, Claudia Grell. Die früher WikiGeks Podcast gemacht haben und jetzt irgendwie schon seit Ewigkeiten ihren neuen Podcast äh vorbereiten.
Forever, dass wir das ganz große neue.
Nee, Chinese Democracy, ne? Ja, also das wird ein ganz, ganz großes Ding.
Ja, das äh bin mir relativ sicher, dass dieses Jahr äh das dann auch mal wieder äh knallt, weil länger kann sie eigentlich gar nicht mehr warten. Und äh Dennis, Dennis Mohard,
gehört auch noch mit dazu, der vor allem auch viel äh technisch äh auf die Reihe äh kriegt, Claudia ist immer so die
Community und äh äh Content Planung und und und Ralf hat sich vor allem der ganzen Bühnenplanung äh angenommen. Wir hatten dann noch äh tatkräftige Unterstützung vom Wok, vor allem von Peter und äh Danimo
sich dort eingebracht haben und äh das was schön war, war das, dass das Sendezentrum dieses Jahr auch so ein bisschen.
Mehr war als jetzt nur so 'ne Podcasting Bühne, sondern es war halt auch vor allem so 'n wurde jetzt auch wahrgenommen als als Entertainment Ort
oder auch einfach lustige Sachen äh stattfanden. Und aber was konkret jetzt äh auch
dieses diese Bühne und und und die Wok Beteiligung betrifft, das ist auch so ein bisschen so ein Experimentierort geworden, also es ist sozusagen so bisschen die Prototyping Stage, wo man
die neuen Sachen ausprobiert, so wie müsste eigentlich eine Bühne verschaltet sein, dass man sie wirklich sehr
effizient und flexibel benutzen kann. So mit verschiedenen Zuspielungen, Video, wo auf welchem Bildschirm wird das jetzt angezeigt, was es auf dem Monitor
Was ist, wenn ich jetzt jemand über Skypri Mode mit dazuhole? Wie kann ich das steuern? Wie, wie, wie, wie läuft das in der
eine Kreuzschiene im Video, weil wie wird das zuverlässig rekordet? Was was muss man alles rekorden? Was ist mit dem Audio? Ist das alles noch synchron? All diese ganzen Fragen
ähm werden da halt äh ja behandelt so
gucken und ich glaube, das wird dann nächstes Jahr noch ein bisschen weitergehen in diese Richtung. Das wäre einfach versuchen, einfach eine eine coole Podcast Bühne da zu prototaten, wo man auch draus lernen kann, auch letztlich für
die Betreibung unserer anderen Bühnen.
Ja, aber eine Sache, die ich mein, niemand, die ihr da noch vielleicht auch eine Frage, die ihr noch angehen könnt, ist so wie beschallt man. Weil das war,
teilweise war da die die Audiobeschallung hatte ich den Eindruck da hätte man noch optimieren können. Da waren teilweise so komische Frequenzen drin, die man nicht wusste,
und äh da da könnte er noch so ein Audio-Nerd mit in euer Team holen.
Den Audi-Nerd, den du gerade im Sinne hast, der äh hat uns das auch berichtet, aber,
zu dem Zeitpunkt alles nicht mehr so richtig zu retten. Äh klar, da ist viel Verbesserungspotential oder auch was die äh Bühne betrifft. Wir müssen natürlich auch ein bisschen aufpassen, wir machen's da relativ breit da in diesem Bereich und äh können jetzt aber nicht auftreten
wie wir wollen muss man schauen wie sich das entwickelt.
Funk-Kopfhörer.
Wird nächstes Jahr, nee, das ist auch nicht, das geht gar nicht.
Bitte gar nicht. Ne.
Das macht ja die Republika, das ist das ist das Schlimmste, was du tun kannst.
Die machen sowas? Echt?
Ja, da gibt's zwei Säte, die nur mit Funk-Kopfhörern arbeiten und das äh für Vorträgen Vortragende ist es, dass das das Schlimmste überhaupt.
Ach so, weil die dann ja aber wieso? Die Leute klatschen doch wahrscheinlich trotzdem oder.
Du hörst es aber nicht.
Dass die Leute klatschen oder dass die dich hören.
Du hast da einfach keinerlei, du bist völlig entkoppelt, du hast das Gefühl, du du sitzt in einer dunklen Kammer und redest mit.
Das ist aber auch nur ein Kopfhörer aufsetzen.
Haben die ja auch, aber das ist dann halt nicht so abgemixt, dass dass da wirklich Atmosphäre rauskommt, dann hörst du irgendwie die die Aktivitäten der der Nachbarstage noch sehr viel lauter und bist vollkommen also das vergiss es einfach. Das ist äh,
keine gute Idee.
Okay. Was kann man denn noch sagen? So, ja, dann war das sehr äh schön, viele Leute zu treffen bei diesem Kongress.
Ja, hat dich das Spaß gemacht?
Ähm ich hoffe, dass ich dass ich äh das ich zu niemandem oder dass ich auf niemanden einen unfreundlichen Eindruck gemacht habe.
Disclama, ich kann mich nicht mehr an alle Momente erinnern, aber ich hoffe, ich war wenigstens freundlich.
Nee, ah das ist ich kann also das,
Das ist also wenn man,
wenn man dann eben bei bestimmten Dingen eingebunden ist und irgendwie wenig schläft und da irgendwie rumgeistert, dann hat man vielleicht auch nicht immer die Zeit auf einen äh die Zeit für ein ruhiges Gespräch, was ähm,
Und auch wenn es interessant ist und muss dann halt teilweise sowas mal ein Gespräch irgendwie,
abrupt verlassen, weil irgendein Telefon klingelt oder weil man bei irgendjemand gerade
mit einem schweren Gewicht in der Hand, seit einer halben Stunde wartet, dass man endlich kommt und äh äh die Todesfalle entfernt oder was auch, also das das äh tut, da habe ich dann nachher immer ein schlechtes Gefühl
am Abend, wenn ich so denke, Mensch, ey, da war doch eine nette Person oder hast die irgendwie so in dreißig Sekunden abgefertigt.
Und äh links liegen lassen, das.
Sicherlich jetzt nicht äh aus. Ich habe mich äh auf jeden Fall mit um um jeden, der mich angesprochen hat.
Ich brauche auch mal so ein Team um mich rum, was dann da irgendwie alles hinstellt und einstellt.
Das ist die.
Ich habe nur nix zu mir hinstellen und einstellen.
Machst das ja auch noch nicht so lang.
Ja, ich bin neu hier. Kann das noch nicht, weiß man nicht, wie das ist, bitte.
Nee, aber ich fand das super, auch alle Hörer, die sich äh vor Ort äh geoutet haben und äh gesagt haben, was sie ähm,
Was sie so hören und so und was da noch so an äh netten Worten,
äh noch mitgegeben wurde. Alles total super. Ich bin erstaunt, wie viele Podcasthörer mittlerweile auf dem Kongress sind oder beziehungsweise wie viele Kongresshörer zum Podcasthörern geworden sind,
Das war ja auch so ein methodisch inkorrekt so lustig, als er das ganz am Anfang so ja,
Hütte war voll, so. Wer hört denn diesen Podcast überhaupt, weil die dachten alle, die wären alle so so ein bisschen auf Verdacht,
dahin gekommen und so, das hat dann also gefühlt achtzig Prozent des Saals hat die Hand gehoben,
Das war so so ein so einen kurzen Moment auf der Bühne ausgelöst hat, dass ich aber auch schnell wieder aufgelöst hat,
Ich war nicht wirklich überrascht, war aber trotzdem sehr äh interessant zu sehen, dass das Podcast mittlerweile zumindest so in der äh
der dem Kulturkreis, der dem Kongress zugeneigt ist, äh offenbar eine feste Größe geworden ist. Und das hat sie auch im Sendezentrum gezeigt und das äh,
finde ich natürlich super.
Ja, da müssen wir jetzt mal irgendwie aufpassen, dass wir dass wir nicht die den die Leute aus den guten Vorträgen raushalten, weil die sich irgendwelche Podcasts anhören.
Wieso raushalten?
Das war ein Scherz. Podcast kannst du auch zu Hause hören.
Ja, wir sollten uns nachher bei den abgelehnten Vorträgen mal ein bisschen tummeln und dann unser Programm.
Kann sich ja in,
Das ist immer das ist das ist leider immer so ein Problem, dass ähm wir schreiben ja immerhin so, ja, wir konnten dein,
leider nicht mit ins Programm aufnehmen. Hast du leider immer wieder auch Personen, die das als äh eine persönliche
Zurückweisung empfinden und das kann ich natürlich auch selber sehr gut nachvollziehen, aber das äh ich mein das Ausmaß dieser Veranstaltung,
in je ich alles, was du irgendwie quantifizieren kannst an dieser Veranstaltung, ist irgendwie Mindlowing, ne, also Einreichungen,
Vorträge, Prozent großartige Vorträge, Sitzplätze in den,
verflucht, Seelen, die viel zu viele sind und äh viel zu viele Besucher, äh viel zu viel Mate, aber war dann doch doch trotzdem nicht genug, weil wurde ausgetrunken. Also das ist äh.
Sitzplätze gibt's eher zu wenig.
Ja, aber das sind zu viele. Zu viel Sitz. Ich habe mir viel zu viel. Dreitausend oder dreieinhalbtausend. Ja eben, ich sage ja.
So wie du warst, gesungen. Wieso? Ist voll. Ja eben, ich sage ja. Was ist denn daran zu viel? Ist zu wenig.
Es kommen ja auch zu viele. Ist ja alles zu viel. Also jede Zahl.
Kommen eigentlich nicht zu viele. Es kommen na ja.
Ist zu viel. Zu laut, zu viel, zu krass.
Also ich habe jetzt diesen Kongress schon mehrere.
Male wohlwollend besucht.
Ja, nicht nur das, sondern ich habe auch ihn mehrere Male so gewisse äh heilige Hürden überspringen sehen, von denen immer alle glaubten, wenn's mal soweit ist
ist alles vorbei, ja? Stell dir mal vor es kommen mehr als tausend Leute auf den Kongress. Stell dir mal vor es werden mehr als dreitausend Leute aufgenommen. Oh Gott, jetzt waren wir sechstausend Leute auf. Was ist erst, wenn wir mal zehntausend Leute sind? Wo soll denn das alles noch hinführen? Jetzt sind wir irgendwie bei,
was weiß ich, zwölf, dreizehntausend und ähm ich habe immer noch nicht das Gefühl, dass das dieser Veranstaltung schadet.
Das wollte ich ja gar nicht sagen. Ich habe nicht gesagt, dass irgendjemand hier der Veranstaltungsschaden. Ich wollte, dass es dieses, also diese, das Ausmaß das Ausmaß ist einfach krass.
Für meinen Geschmack könnte es nicht genug Sitzplätze sein, ja. Das Ausmaß ist krass. Ausmaße ist einfach. Hast du so zu viel im Sinne von, wie man das so überhaupt noch verarbeiten soll?
Ja, Tim, äh so, genau, also so ich bin ja ähm.
Zu geil. Es ist zu geil, es geht so nicht weiter. Nein. Was sollen wir machen, wenn das noch geiler wird?
Weiß ich auch nicht.
Das war aber doch jetzt ein ziemlich langer Epilog, oder Tim?
Oder Prolog, je nachdem, wie man's sieht.
Mann, ey, das lerne ich nie. Da kann man sehen, hier meine bildungsferne Sozialisation. Versteht noch nicht mal Prolog und Epilog, ja?
Na egal. Hauptsache Hauptsache Content. So Linus, jetzt ist aber hier auch Ende erstmal. Mehr Kongress kriege ich jetzt auch nicht mehr rausgepresst.
Ich auch nicht. Ich äh bin auch noch ganz ha ganz überwältigt. Jetzt haben wir und jetzt haben wir, wie viel, so kurz eigentlich nur, ne? Ganz kurze, ganz kurze.
Ja, ja, sehr überschaubar.
Sehr überschaubar. Besonders interessant irgendwie äh ist wahrscheinlich die uninteressanteste Sendung, die wir je gemacht haben.
Bitte. Er ist auch interessant.
Einen Talk nach dem anderen runter. Wenn wir zwei Stunden Sendung und wenn die Leute jetzt jedes Mal auf Pause drücken, dann den Tor gucken.
Ha.
Haben wir verloren, für immer. Hören wir nie wieder.
Naja, kann man kann man sich ein halbes Jahr mit beschäftigen wahrscheinlich.
Und es geht in der Tat eigentlich ganz, ganz äh flott. Man hat dann halt so eine App, so ein App-Spielgerät und hat da die Playliste drin und wenn man dann eben da ist, dann drückt man halt auf Play und hört.
App Spielgerät fort.
Ja, wir haben ja leider auf deinem Apple TV geht's ja leider nicht. Hast du das denn wenigstens mal flashen lassen? Hast du dir machen lassen?
Geht's jetzt? Nee, es geht ja auch. Es gibt ja hier die zweiunddreißig C drei App vom Toto. Der war ja ein bisschen pfiffiger in seiner Einreichungsmethodik.
Und der hat dann nachher erst die Videofunktion nachgeliefert oder was?
Ob da einen für die Review ein spezielles Angebot, was sie reviewen konnten.
Hat der der,
Der ist echt tatsächlich, weil das, also dann muss der ja mit. Da musste ja Kollaborateure gehabt haben.
Hört das einfach ganz normal eingereicht,
Die haben das dann reviewt und haben drauf geklickt und geguckt, was es da für Talks gibt. Ah da gibt's genau einen. Irgendwas mit Netzpolitik in der Schweiz. Wollte ich mich erinnere. Ja, den haben die sich angeschaut, haben gesagt, okay,
ich war jetzt im Store. Kann man leider nicht drauf linken, weil da gerade nicht so drauf linken kann, aber zweiunddreißig C drei äh Apple TV, ihr seid dabei. Da ist dann auch der Rest.
Das ist, ist jetzt eine andere als die Congress App, die er.
Ja ja, das ist was anderes. Nein, das also das ist im Prinzip dieselbe App für Apple TV in einer App.
Weil dann heißt sie nicht zweiunddreißig zu drei, dann heißt sie Congress.
Kann auch sein, dass sie Kongress heißt, ich habe sie jetzt noch nicht äh gesucht, aber es gibt sie.
Ja.
Von wegen hier geht es Community. Tour aufgestoßen. Mit Pfiffigkeit.
Mit mit Pfeffichkeit,
Okay Tim.
Das war's. Jungs, Mädels, da draußen war schön mit euch.
Frohes neues Jahr.
Genau. Gibt demnächst auch noch ein schnelles Spezial hinterher. Wir haben eine Menge äh im Angebot, werdet ihr dann sehen. Aber bis dahin erstmal tschüss.
Ciao, ciao.